Ihr hört CAE Technikkultur, Gesellschaft, mein Name ist Tim Brittloff und ich sag hallo zu allen, die wieder reingeschaltet haben zur 223. Folge von CAE mittlerweile, große Zahlen
Heute hat mich der Weg nach Köln geführt, weil ich ein wenig eintauchen möchte in die,
Ich sage mal, vor allem in die westdeutsche Gesellschaftsgeschichte und dann auch mit einem speziellen Blick aufs Fernsehen, ganz konkret aufs,
Kinder, Fernsehen und freue mich sehr über meinen Gesprächspartner heute, nämlich den Armin Armin Meiwald, hallo.
Hallo. Ähm der äh das Intro klang ja schon sehr nach Weltraum und und Fernwelten.
Das äh war die Absicht. Genau, hier wollen wir ja weit reisen mental zumindest, mental reisen. Ja.
Fangen wir an? Also
ähm ist kein Geheimnis, äh die meisten Leute werden nicht mit äh der Sendung mit der Maus äh primär assoziieren. Kein Wunder, 50 Jahre lang diese Sendung äh geprägt. Das bleibt nicht aus. Aber,
ja auch mal eine Zeit, wo das nicht so war und ähm.
Der Anfang war eher holprig als äh berühmt oder berüchtigt.
Kann ich mir gut vorstellen und das ist eigentlich auch so ein bisschen das, wo ich äh drauf hinaus bin,
Ähm das Ganze ist also zwangsläufig auch so eine kleine äh Zeitreise und das ist ja im Prinzip dann auch so ein wenig die Geschichte der Bundesrepublik äh Deutschland. Also des Westens muss man ja sagen,
sich dann nach dem Krieg auf seine Art neu äh gefunden hat. Ähm ist ja auch so dem dem Krieg entwachsen, kann man sagen, ne? Wer ich? Ja.
Wer ich? Ja ja klar, ich bin ja im Krieg geboren, ne? Ja, sicher. Und habe auch die ganze Nachkriegszeit natürlich noch miterlebt und zwar ziemlich hautnah.
Ja. Also geboren, glaube ich, neunzehnhundertvierzig, richtig? Ja. Ja.
Januar 40 also äh im Januar ne gleich äh zu Beginn des Jahres und äh neununddreißig ging der Krieg ja erst los im äh September.
Berühmten äh Überfall,
empfohlen da und na ja, danach ungefähr vier, fünf Monate später bin ich geboren worden, also mitten äh in diesem ganzen Theater da.
Dem Theater. Wann kriegt man das erste Mal was davon mit?
Na ja nur ich hab's äh relativ früh mitgekriegt, weil äh
meine Mutter ist mit mir als Baby schon äh zu meinem Vater gefahren, der eingezogen war, also meine Eltern mussten ja das Geschäft zumachen, mein Vater war Konditormeister.
Das war hier in Köln hm.
Und äh meine Mutter war natürlich keine Konditorin und äh insofern
wo also der Meister weg war, der Chef äh war das Geschäft nicht weiterzuführen, denn die ganzen Kerdo waren ja irgendwie eingezogen oder sowas, mein Vater eben auch und
äh der hat also nie groß Karriere beim Militär gemacht. Äh der höchste Auszeichnung war, glaube ich, Oberbefreiter. Also er hatte so einen Winkel am Arm. Ich habe ihn nur
zweimal in meinem Leben überhaupt gesehen. Einmal eher unbewusst. Äh das war wohl neunzehnhundertzweiundvierzig, also da hat er wohl Heimaturlaub gehabt und ist hier in Köln gewesen.
In der Konditorei, wo er seinen Meister gemacht hat und wollte das auch noch mal seine alten Kumpels besuchen
und äh ich erinnere mich noch deutlich, dass meine Mutter gesagt hat, äh komm, wir gehen mal den Papa besuchen und da war ich wahrscheinlich an der Hand irgendwie, ein kleiner Typ,
zwei Jahre oder so.
Und äh ich weiß, das war am Neumarkt das Café, es ging so ein paar Stufen runter und dann musste durch das Café in die Backstube und da standen also unheimlich viele weiße Leute, einer davon war mein Vater
ich glaube, ich habe ihn gar nicht erkannt, aber er wird mich wohl auf den Arm genommen haben, aber daran habe ich keine Erinnerung. Bloß wie wir in das Café gingen, durch das Café und dann in die Backstube und da unheimlich viele weiße Leute standen,
und einer davon war mein Vater. Und das zweite Mal habe ich ihn gesehen 19fünfvierzigund, da waren wir aber schon äh
X mal durch die Republik gereist, also von Köln erst nach Schlesien, von Schlesien nach München, von München nach Weilheim, von Weilheim nach äh nach Uffing.
Äh da waren wir dann einquartiert, ne, so mit einem Einweisungsschein, wie das ja damals war.
Also schon auf der Flucht.
Ja ja, klar, ja, ja,
Also ich war an diesem berühmten zehn3 Februar in Dresden. Wir sind mit dem sogenannten letzten Zug da rausgekommen. Ich weiß nicht, der wievielte letzte Zug oder der allerletzte es war. Jedenfalls ich erinnere mich nur da dran. Äh äh an diese Geschichte
weil ich ausnahmsweise nicht im Gepäcknetz gereist bin, also Kinder reisten traditionell sonst oben auf den Koffern im Gepäcknetz, weil unten die Züge natürlich alle voll waren
Und dieser letzte Zug war nun irgendwie ausm Boden gestampft worden, um möglichst viele Leute aus Dresden rauszukriegen.
In Dresden wohnte meine Großtante glaube ich äh die habe ich dann später noch ein zwei Mal gesehen
Dresden war ja dann DDR und da konnte man nicht hin. Und war ja für uns hier im Westen war das ja
alles, was hinter der sogenannten Demarkationslinie damals war war ja ein weißer Fleck auf der Landkarte, ne? Also man wusste ja gar nicht, also wenn sie mich vor zehn Jahren gefragt hätten, wo Dresden liegt, hätte ich gesagt, na ja irgendwo im Osten mehr wusste ich nicht.
Ist nicht falsch.
Nee, das stimmt auch heute noch. Natürlich selbstverständlich,
Aber mittlerweile bin ich äh ich weiß nicht, wie oft in Dresden gewesen und habe da auch gedreht und so und äh klar. Aber damals äh ich erinnere mich deswegen, weil ich eben nicht im Gepäcknetz reiste, sondern ausnahmsweise unten am
Fenster stand und der Zug fuhr aus aus Dresden raus und man sah also die Bombeneinschläge und das Feuer und so. Also auch ein Bild, das ich äh wahrscheinlich nie vergessen werde. Äh ich könnte es vielleicht noch zeichnen, aber
Muss ja nicht sein. Also.
Schönere Erinnerungen.
Es gibt schönere Erinnerungen, ne und dann äh waren wir halt in Uffing evakuiert, nachdem wir also dann erst München, dann Mailand äh dann äh aufhängen. Und mein Vater war zu der Zeit
dann nach Freising versetzt. Das ist in der Gegend von München. Ich weiß nicht, wie gut sie sich in der Landschaft auskennen.
Also äh Freising ist mir bekannt. Uffing musste ich jetzt gerade mal nachschlagen.
Am Staffelsee. Das ist ungefähr auf der halben Strecke zwischen München und.
Im Süden Bayerns.
Am Staffelsee ja. Eigentlich äh äh eine schöne Gegend da, also im Alpenvorland.
Und äh da ist mein Vater dann mit dem Fahrrad von der Kaserne in Freising nach Uffing gekommen, um seine Familie zu besuchen und musste aber am nächsten Morgen wieder in der Kaserne sein und dann haben wir ihn
da war meine Schwester dann schon geboren, die war dann schon drei und ich fünf und mein Vater das Fahrrad genommen, hat also mit dem Bauch am Lenker gehangen und hatte rechts und links an der Hand jeweils eins von seinen beiden Kindern und
äh dann haben wir ihn von dem Haus, wo wir da evakuiert waren. Das war direkt neben dem Bahnhof, also,
500 Meter vielleicht und da haben wir ihn zum Bahnhof gebracht und dann ist er im Zug, dann das Fahrrad, dann Gepäckwagen und ist dann zurück nach Freising.
Und acht oder zehn Tage später war er tot, aber das wussten wir nicht. Das haben wir erst sehr viel später erfahren und äh das war das zweite Mal, dass ich meinen Vater gesehen habe. Also meinen Vater kenne ich also bloß von so ein paar äh Fotos,
wirklich die meine Mutter dann hatte und äh ja, das war alles, was ich von meinem Vater.
Kenne oder ich habe dann erst sehr viel später. Der hat wohl irgendwann, als er im Lazarett äh war wohl verwundet gewesen.
Hat da wohl ein Tagebuch geschrieben über seine eigene Kindheit und dieses Schulheft, das er damals irgendwo in dem Lazarett geschrieben hat. Das hat also sowohl den Krieg als auch die ganzen Umzüge und
irgendwas in irgendeinem Koffer überlebt
und irgendwie vor drei Jahren jetzt, ne, hat meine Schwester das irgendwo aus irgendeinem alten,
Pappkarton rausgezogen und sagt, hör mal, ich habe hier was, das kann ich nicht lesen. Ich glaube, äh das ist vom Vati.
Deutsche Schrift. Richtig. Mhm.
Also ich habe die ja noch in der Schule gelernt
also äh neben der Blockschrift natürlich. Blockschrift war damals also 1945 der Hit in Tüten überhaupt, weil äh damit habe ich also,
das erste Geld verdient in Anführungszeichen, Geld nicht wirklich, weil Geld war ja nichts wert sondern eben im Tauschhandel, weil äh wenn man Adressen schreiben musste damals,
neunzehnhundert5undvierzig, da mussten die in Blockschrift geschrieben sein, weil die Alliierten, die deutsche Schrift nicht lesen konnten, sonst wurde der Brief gar nicht befördert und der ging dann wahrscheinlich sowieso durch die Zensur oder was der Teufel war.
Also Blockschrift unsere heutige Schreibform.
Ja, nee, also richtig mit großen Buchstaben, großen Buchstaben, ja
und ich konnte das irgendwie. Ich habe also schon schreiben können, als ich noch lange nicht in der Schule war, ne? Verrückterweise.
Keine Ahnung, woher ich das wusste. Es hat mir keiner beigebracht. Ich konnte das einfach.
Weil die das wussten so die Erwachsenen kamen die dann und sagt kannst du uns mal die Adresse schreiben? Mussten wir natürlich alles buchstabieren jeden Namen und jede Straße und jeden Ort und so weil ich die natürlich noch nicht kannte und dann habe ich diese Adressen also Buchstabenweise geschrieben und dann
so eine Adresse dann fertig war, so mit Absender und allem drum und dran, dann konnte man damit schon mal, was weiß ich, äh ein halbes Brot oder so was äh im im Tausch kriegen, ne. Das war ja.
Aha okay.
War ja äh richtig so was, ne oder ein paar Zigaretten-Zigaretten.
Alles alles was man konnte war eigentlich auch irgendwas wert.
Ja natürlich, klar, klar. Ich habe dann äh von einem Onkel, der dann irgendwann auch aus Kriegsgefangenschaft
äh entlassen wurde, der war in Garmisch-Partenkirchen an der Jägerkaserne der war Elektroingenieur und von dem habe ich dann auch mit fünf oder sechs spätestens gelernt Bügeleisen zu reparieren und die damals Kochplatten, die hatten ja solche äh
Heizspiralen, ne, die gleichzeitig als Kochplatten dienten, wenn's denn mal Strom gab und gleichzeitig aber auch als Zigarettenanzünder, ne? Man
Streichhölzer gab's ja genauso wenig,
Und dann hört man eben an diesen äh Kochplatten die Zigarette angezündet, was häufig dazu führte, dass dann einfach diese äh Heizspiralen durchbrannten, ne und äh
dann konnte man da neue einziehen und das waren die lagen ja offen, ne. Das war also nicht wie heute so eine Kochplatte wo oben.
Nix, gar nix, ne, sondern die glühten richtig vor sich hin und das war so ein Keramik.
Body in so Schlangenlinien und da musste man dann neue äh Spiralen einziehen, wenn man denn welche irgendwo
kam oder man musste die zusammenfriemeln und dann wieder neu einziehen und ein bisschen zusammenlöten, ne? Also das konnte dann äh mein Onkel und ich konnte dann mit den kleinen Fingern konnte ich also prima da durch diese Keramikspirallöcher oder
Schlangenlinien besser gesagt konnte ich diese einziehen und dann hinten auch wieder am Stecker festmachen und so. War natürlich auch
ein gutes Geschäft, ne? Da kriegte man einen Liter Milch für oder halt irgendwas zum Essen oder so. Hm. So war das damals.
Man schlug sich durch. Fünfundvierzig Krieg war vorbei, ganze Land lag in äh Ruinen und vor allem musste sie sich's ja erst mal wieder muss ja erst mal wieder alles zu Besinnungen kommen im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Wenn meine Erinnerung richtig ist, war damals in unserem Landkreis war damals der Franz-Josef Strauss, der Landrat von Schongau, glaube ich, Oha ja, wie auch immer.
Oha.
Kann sein, dass die Erinnerung falsch ist, aber ich meine mich zu erinnern, dass äh irgendwie in der untersten Ebene des meines Gehirns irgendwo gespeichert zu haben.
Wann beginnt denn so die äh bewusste Wahrnehmung der Umgebung bei dir so, dass du das Gefühl hast, jetzt kannst du die Gesellschaft auch so ein bisschen einschätzen.
Relativ früh. Also ich kann mich sehr weit zurückerinnern eben auch an an viele Reisen von A nach B und so was und spätestens also
in Uffingen, wo ich dann also fünf war, also ich habe ja eben schon erzählt, dass Adressen schreiben oder Zigarettenkippen auflesen von den amerikanischen Besatzungssoldaten. Wir waren also damals in der amerikanischen Zone
und die Amis hatten das natürlich voll drauf. Die wussten sehr genau, dass die Jungs dann die Zigaretten kippen.
Ölaufnahmen und daraus neue Zigaretten gebaut haben und die haben mir die manchmal nur angeraucht und dann gleich weggeworfen, das war natürlich äh,
war Verschwendung, aber für uns natürlich super, weil brauchte man bloß vorne ein bisschen den Brand ab und hinten waren ja noch keine Filterzigaretten. Sondern ich weiß nicht, Gold-Dollar und so Zeug äh äh und Lucky Strike.
Waren so die Marken, die es damals gab, also in Erinnerung, vielleicht gab's auch noch mehr, ich weiß es nicht, aber das waren die, die mir in Innung geblieben sind.
Und dann äh was weiß ich mit Zeitungspapier, so wie die russischen Papiere Papierauszeichnungspapier nehmen, neue Rollen und dann äh.
War die Zigarette.
Erst wieder die Zigarette, fünf Zigaretten ein Kilo Brot oder so was, ne? Das war oder irgend so was, ne,
es gab ja also Lebensmittelmarken und da musste man ja eben dann beim Kaufmann musste man in den langen Schlangen anstehen, um überhaupt irgendwas zu kriegen. Das wurde dann auch immer aufgerufen. Was weiß ich, heute,
von 100 Gramm Zucker oder sonst irgendwas, ne? Also Mangelware war damals also schon angesagt, ne? Und das also,
Kann mich auch erinnern, dass wir da in dem Haus wo wir dann äh einquartiert waren und die hatten einen großen Garten und da stand meine Schwester und ich dann manchmal morgens um 11 schon und rief nach oben zum
Küchenfans, das war so eine Gemeinschaftsküche, wo alle, die da einquartiert waren, gemeinschaftlich die Küche benutzen mussten. Mama, wann gibt's was zu essen oder so, ne? Also
weil Frühstück war vielleicht ein Stückchen Brot mit irgendwas drauf, vielleicht auch mit gar nix,
Und dann hatte man natürlich permanent Hunger, ne, klar.
Französisch Strauß war übrigens wirklich der Landrat in Schongau ab 46, er ist der stellvertretende und dann nochmal zwei Jahre richtig Landrat.
Kann sein, ja. Also war war meine Erinnerung gar nicht so falsch.
Ja. Ähm wo sind wir jetzt? Neunzehnhundertfünfzig. Ich meine, irgendwann setzte so dieses.
Eine 50 war dann äh war für mich ja ein ein äh ein merkwürdiges Jahr, weil ich dann 1950 kam ich also aufs Gymnasium,
nach Weilheim,
Musste ich also jeden Morgen im Zug hinfahren, ne? Gab's also erst eine Aufnahmeprüfung. Und äh die da dachte ich schon, ich hätte die Aufnahmenprüfung versemmelt, weil äh da gab's,
auch so ein Bogen, heute würde man sagen, so ein Fragebogen, wo man dann also einzelne Wörter die fehlten, ergänzen musste und dann war da ein Satz, den werde ich auch nicht vergessen,
gab äh Körner in Hü und.
Und mir wurde also partout nicht einfallen, was hü und fü der nun sein könnte. Und da habe ich hingeschrieben in Hülsen und Füglein, weil in Hülle und Fülle
Wäre mir also nicht im Mindesten eingefallen. Da dachte ich schon, damals hätte ich also die Aufnahmeprüfung versemmelt, war aber.
Nicht schlecht für dich.
Ja, zumindest Fantasieleistung.
Okay. Wurde anerkannt.
Ja, ich habe dann die Aufnahmeprüfung bestanden und war dann Fahrschüler. Jeden Morgen um zehn nach sieben im Zug nach Weilheim,
20 Minuten Fahrt etwa.
Fahrschüler im Sinne von einem Schüler, der zur Schule fahren muss.
Musste ja, jeden Morgen aufm Zug, Sommer und Winter und dann äh in Weilheim durch den ganzen Ort, das Gymnasium lag also ein bisschen außerhalb
also musst du über den Marktplatz und so noch ein paar Straßen
bin da vor zwei Jahren oder so was bin ich dann nochmal gewesen und hab versucht ob ich den Weg noch finde hab nichts mehr wiedererkannt bis auf den Marktplatz mit der Kirche der also noch der Alte war mehr oder weniger
und das Gymnasium sieht auch heute völlig anders aus. Bin da drin gewesen, sie haben einen riesen neuen Anbau und äh da haben wir dann in äh
in der ersten Fremdsprache mit Englisch angefangen in Bayern,
äh auch eins, eine eins der Dinge, an die ich mich erinnere. Unser Englischlehrer, der kam rein und sagte,
My name is Hunter. Wir hatten natürlich keine Ahnung und dann hat er uns erklärt, dass er Jäger heißt und so, ne und das war also der erste englische Satzhunter. Na ja,
Und dann war ich im Jahr 1951 eigentlich schon in die Quinta versetzt, also das erste Jahr hieß ja sechster. Die damalige ist ja immer sechster Quinterquarter und das ja Oberteil und so weiter. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich diese Zählung noch irgendwas sage.
Ja, ich habe auch so den einen oder anderen Heinz Rühlmann-Film gesehen. Da kommt das zu.
Ja ja klar und 51 war ich eigentlich schon in die Quinta versetzt, aber mitten im Sommer sind wir dann von Uffing,
zunächst nach Neuss gezogen, weil Köln hatte ja absolutes Zuzugsverbot, war ja alles kaputt in Köln.
Und äh man konnte also gar nicht nach Köln, aber äh eine Tante, also eine Schwester meiner Mutter mit ihrem Mann, diesem Onkel, dem Elektroingenieur, die waren also irgendwie,
vor Gefahren in den sogenannten Westen und suchten also da irgendeine Bleibe, haben dann auch ein Zimmer gefunden, ein einzelnes Zimmer,
äh ich erinnere mich noch, dass meine Mutter also als meine Tante wegfuhr, sagte Christel, lass uns um Gottes Willen hier nicht in Uffing versauern. Guck, dass du für uns irgendwie eine Bude auftreiben kannst und,
die hatte das dann tatsächlich geschafft, auch in Neuss für uns so ein Massadenzimmer äh aufzureißen irgendwo ganz oben unterm Dach, juche.
Äh dann sind wir im Sommer glaube im Juni, also die Ferien hatten schon begonnen
äh umgezogen und äh die Versetzung wäre glaube ich im August oder sowas gewesen.
Dann sind wir nach Neuss und dann äh wollte ich eigentlich natürlich, weil ich ja versetzt war in Neuss in die Quinta kommen. Meine Mutter ist mit mir dann da zu dem Direktor gegangen und wollte mich anmelden und hat so gesagt ja,
Das wird wohl nix, weil wir fangen hier mit Latein an und dann musste ich nochmal in die Sechster. Also ich habe insgesamt äh nicht neun Jahre Gymnasium, sondern elf Jahre Gymnasium hinter mich gebracht. Und ich musste noch mal in die Sechster,
aber die Finger in Nordrhein-Westfalen ja mit der Versetzung Ostern an und wir waren also im Sommer umgezogen, also ich musste ein halbes Jahr Latein nachholen
einem äh äh Priesterschüler, der das dann in 30 Stunden mehr eingebumst hat, was zur Folge hatte, dass meine äh äh Verhältnis zur lateinischen Sprache
zunächst immer etwas sehr getrübt war, weil wenn man das dann so.
Nole ins Wohnens nachholen muss und das eigentlich gar nicht will und noch mal in die 1te Klasse zurückversetzt werden soll. Das ist natürlich für so ein Typ von zehn Jahren ist das natürlich schon ein Schlag in die Magengrube. Na ja, aber
äh dann war das so und dann,
Bin ich da in Neuss noch zwei Jahre aufm Gymnasium gewesen bis 1953 und 1953 hatte
mein Onkel es dann tatsächlich geschafft hier in Köln eine Riesenwohnung für die Reste der Familie, die dann nach dem Krieg noch übrig geblieben war, alle zusammen in eine große Wohnung
zu ziehen, also Onkel, Tante, meine Mutter, meine Schwester, ich und meine Großmutter alles zusammen in eine große Wohnung hier im belgischen Viertel in Köln, in in in der Genterstraße am Friesenplatz.
Und das war natürlich äh zum ersten Mal Großstadt, also äh alleine vom Dorf, von
uffhängen. Das war also ein richtiges 800-Seelen-Dauf, ein kleines Dorf nach Neuss, wo man also zum ersten Mal eine Straßenbahn sah. War schon irgendwie ein Kulturschock,
und dann von Neuss nach Köln nochmal äh dann wenn man dann am Friesenplatz stand, dann konnte man vom Friesenplatz bis zum Dom schauen,
ohne dass da irgendwas Störendes dazwischen stand. Also war alles weggeräumt ne also durch den durch den Krieg also kaputt.
Alles im Eimer.
Alles im Eimer, ne? Und äh ja, dann bin ich hier in Köln dann wieder aufs Gymnasium gegangen, ne,
gerade äh.
In der Zeit äh in das Gymnasium gekommen, als dieses Gymnasium, das vorher bei einem Mädchen-Gymnasium zur Untermiete wohnte, wo dann also noch äh Schichtunterricht war
die Mädels vormittags, die Jungs nachmittags und dann wurde wochenweise gewechselt und dann kam der Neubau und,
Ich bin gerade in den Neubau reingekommen, also der der roch, der roch so nach Farbe hier im Grüngürtel, also Gymnasium Kreuzgasse, da war ich dann bis zum Schluss, ja.
Welchen Zustand befand sich dann die Umgebung abgesehen jetzt von den zerstörten Gebäuden, also fuffziger Jahre haben wir dann so ein bisschen das sogenannte Wirtschaftswunder, was ja eigentlich so ein gesamt-europäisches Phänomen war,
Nachkrieg äh ausgelöst so. Was hat das so mit der Gesellschaft gemacht wie ein.
Na ja nur also.
Verhältnis hat sich auch so zurück gegenüber dieser Kriegssituation eingestellt, weil es so aus den Augen aus dem Sinn.
Ja äh ich denke schon hauptsächlich, weil die meisten Leute hatten eben äh viele hatten alles verloren, waren irgendwie geflüchtet,
äh die Kerle waren irgendwie im Krieg geblieben und äh ich meine was ich ja bis heute nicht verstehe in der Kriegszeit haben die Mädels ja alles
unter sich ausgemacht, ne? Die sind Lokomotiven gefahren und äh Straßenbahnen und weiß der Teufel, was alles, ne. Es gab Stationsvorsteherinnen,
dass die nach dem Krieg dann nicht zu den Kern, die dann zurückkamen, gesagt haben
Hört mal ihr Armleuchter. Ihr habt jetzt genug Scheiße angerichtet. Haltet euch mal schön zurück. Wir machen das. Wir haben's ja jetzt die letzten Jahre sowieso alles schon gemanagt. Wir kriegen aber nein,
dann äh rollte sich das alles komplett zurück und die haben's ja mit der Blüschen genäht aus Fallschirm-Seide und haben also so getan, als
sie das andere vorher nie gemacht? Ich habe das nie verstanden bis auf den heutigen Tag nicht, ne, dass da also nicht äh die äh Frauenpower, wenn man so will, sich durchgesetzt hat.
Aber viele haben dann eben auch alles verdrängt
bei den Kerlen kann man's natürlich sich vorstellen. Die hatten also irgendwelche äh Schlachten oder irgendwelche furchtbaren Sachen hinter sich oder kamen aus der Gefangenschaft meinetwegen auch aus Russland oder so was.
Aller Art.
Wollten ja aber das Wort Trauma war damals noch nicht erfunden. Dafür gab's auch keine Zeit, ne? Also.
Aber das war's.
Das war's ja sicher und äh äh insofern wurde da eigentlich zunächst über den Krieg oder so was,
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass da jemals drüber gesprochen wurde, auch so bei Bekannten von äh Onkel, Tante, meiner Mutter, so weiß die da noch überhaupt gab. Äh.
Weil damit ja natürlich auch in gewisser Hitze so eine Schuldfrage auch verbunden war.
Gewesen wäre, ja, ja. Aber äh das war natürlich so. Also ich meine, theoretisch,
kriegt hier jeder, der damals im Dritten Reich geheiratet hatte äh mein Kampf als Buch äh ähm bei der Trauung automatisch mitgeliefert und wenn man das gelesen hätte, hätte man
eigentlich sehen können oder erahnen können, was der Gröfarts da irgendwie vorhatte. Aber wahrscheinlich ist dieses Buch, wie die Bibel dann auch irgendwo,
ungelesen äh gesteckt worden. Jedenfalls äh niemand hat irgendwas gewusst,
alle Märkten aber, dass plötzlich irgendwelche Leute fehlten, die dann früher Nachbarn gewesen waren, aber haben sich auch nicht,
traut sich das oder da irgendwie zu hinterfragen oder sowas und äh ich nehme an, dass da schon auch eine eine gewisse Menge an Schuldbewusstsein da war, aber eben nicht genau definiert, was habe ich persönlich getan oder sowas. Also,
der Kreis der Mitläufer in Anführungszeichen, so wurde man ja dann auch bei der Endnazifizierung manchmal eingestuft. Ich weiß nicht, ob wen der Begriff irgendwas sagt. Mitläufer war also mehr oder weniger fast ein Persilschein, ne.
Ja nee aber.
Heute eher negativ konnotiert, aber da ja noch.
Ja äh damals
war's eben die Möglichkeit, wenn man so einen Persilschein hatte, dann konnte man äh sage ich mal, eine Arbeit finden oder sowas, weil wenn man dann äh irgendwie schwer belastet war oder es stand zu befürchten, dass man irgendwie dann noch vor einem Gericht
gestellt wurde oder so was. Also
dem Vernehmen nach. Das habe ich also nicht aus eigenem hörte man immer wieder, dass die Leute dann nach irgendwelchen äh Zeugen suchten, die ihn dann noch irgendwie äh gute
Geschichten äh erzählten, wieso sie sich dann doch im äh im Dritten Reich dann einigermaßen ordentlich verhalten hätten. Wie auch immer. Also.
Das sind alles Sachen, die eigentlich sehr viel später rauskamen.
Jetzt ähm sind wir irgendwo so Mitte der ähFünfziger-jahre ähm,
und es gab ja auch eine technische Revolution in gewisser Hinsicht also auf vielen Ebenen, aber natürlich dann eben auch konkret mit dem Einzug des Fernsehens, was ja dann.
Er hat es kam ja sehr viel später.
Dem Radio folgte.
Ja also ich meine wir hatten zunächst erstmal auch kein Radio. Das kam also auch erst später und dann war so eine alte Gurke, die irgendwie.
Also kein Empfänger. Radio gab's ja.
Natürlich gab's Radio, ne, aber der Empfänger war irgendwie,
aus den zwanziger oder dreißiger Jahren, ne? Also und das war natürlich alles auch Mittelwelle erstmal. Nur wo das dann auch immer so mit raus war war das wieder weg und dann war's wieder deutlicher. Und äh ja
irgendwann so, ich glaube 6undfuffzig oder so was, wurde Fernsehen äh äh erfunden, nicht erfunden, erfunden war es ja schon vorher in den in den dreißiger Jahren. Das war jetzt.
War ja schon unterwegs.
Naja und in bei der bei den Olympischen Spielen neunzehnhundert
äh sechsunddreißig oder so gab's ja sogar schon richtige Live-Übertragungen mit allem drum und dran, also Adolf hat das natürlich auch sofort als äh,
Instrument eingesetzt. Also erfunden war es das, natürlich nur für einen kleinen Kreis. Da gab's ja diese sogenannten Fernsehstuben. Äh wo die Leute sehr gestaunt haben, dass sie irgendwas gesehen haben, was nicht um die Ecke war.
Aber wir hatten selbstverständlich keinen Fernseher. Das war also äh auch äh,
was weiß ich viel zu teuer, ne? Also ich bin äh neunzehnhundertsechsundfünfzig zum ersten Mal in ein Fernsehstudio gekommen, also auch eher
zufällig äh weil ich äh in der Schule eigentlich eine relativ große Klappe hatte und äh der der westdeutsche Rundfunkherz wohl an alle Schulen und so was in Köln ein Brief geschrieben. Sie suchten also
Mitstreiter bei so einer Diskussionssendung die es da gab, so eine Jugenddiskussionssendung und dann kam der Direktor durch die Klasse und fragte, wer geht freiwillig dahin? Hat sicherlich keiner gemeldet und hat gesagt, okay
freiwillig meldet, dann wird der da hingeschickt. Zwangs äh geschickt, der mit der großen Schnauze hat, endlich mal.
Und so kam ich also mit sechzehn, ich glaube, es war sechsundfünfzig oder spätestens siebenundfünfzig äh zum ersten Mal ein Fernsehstudio.
Und das war natürlich schon äh ein irres Ding, weil ähm da liefen die Kameraleute mit Kopfhörern aufm,
Kopf rum und bewegten sich wie ferngestreut mit ihren Kameras durch das Studio. Wo ich nicht verstanden habe, wie das funktionierte.
Das war dann der WDR.
Bei der WDR, ja.
Das war äh das einzige Studio, was der WDR damals hatte, das äh Studium gibt's heute noch, ist allerdings äh jetzt das Studio für die Big Band. Also damals war das das einzige Fernsehstudio. Ich weiß nicht, kennen sich in Köln aus?
Da vorne ist ja der Dom.
Gegenübers ist das Café Reichert und wenn man dann die kleine Straße Burgmau hochgeht, hinter dem Kaffee Reichert links rein, da ist noch der alte Eingang und da an diesem alten Eingang war das sogenannte Studio K,
Technik für das Studio saß oben drüber und äh alles anderen Sachen äh das habe ich dann auch erst später erfahren, als ich dann schon dafür gearbeitet habe für einen Sender. Äh,
wenn die große Produktion hatten, dann ging die
nach Düsseldorf ins Apollo oder äh in Radheuner gab's so eine ehemalige Tanzscheune. Da wurden das Fernsehspiele aufgezeichnet. Da musste dann immer um 5 Uhr Pause gemacht werden, weil dann der einzige Flieger in Köln-Bonn landet
und dann das äh Geräusch war natürlich äh,
in der Scheune zu hören, weil die nicht gedämmt waren, nicht wirklich, ne? Oder in die Rot-Weiß-Halle, in die Tennishalle, da in in Müngersdorf im neben dem Fußballstadion. Da wurden dann die großen,
Spielfilme oder Fernsehspiele aufgezeichnet äh gefilmt, ne, damals noch mit Filmen.
Welche Bedeutung hatte zu dem Zeitpunkt Fernsehen,
In Deutschland. Es gab ja nicht so viele Leute, die jetzt wirklich einen Fernseher hatten. Das war ja dann auch, sagen wir mal, eher Entertainment für die Leute, die schon etwas gefestigter waren, finanziell.
Also es war natürlich was Neues, ne? Und also
Ich erinnere mich, das habe ich dann später, als ich selbst schon Filme gemacht habe, mal aufm Schneidetisch gehabt. Da gab's ein Ehrenfeld, ein hier und heute also diese äh Regionalberichterstattung hatte da auch einen Bericht drüber gemacht.
Um mit dem Kranwagen so ein großes Fernsehmöbel von außen am Haus durch die Dachlücke oben in das Haus reingesetzt wurde. Sehr zum äh Vergnügen der anderen Anwohner in dem Viertel da, weil
dass da ein Fernsehgerät, das war so eine Truhe, ne? Mit einem Kran angeliefert wurde. Das war natürlich schon sensation.
Fernsehmöbel trifft's glaube ich schon wirklich sehr gut, ne und das war so alles voll integriert.
Aber das war nur für wenige und ich meine ich selbst habe schon mehrere Jahre fürs Fernsehen gearbeitet und hatte selbst noch keinen Fernsehapparat,
ne? Aber es war viel zu teuer. Und wenn ich mir irgendwas angucken musste, was weiß ich für eine andere Sendung oder sowas, dann muss hier ein Sender gehen und musste es mir da angucken.
Weil zu Hause hatten wir keinen. Da war mein Sohn schon geboren. Der ist 67 geboren und da war der schon äh ich sage mal fast ein Jahr alt. Da habe ich mir den ersten Fernsehapparat leisten können.
Ne, weil muss sich vorstellen, also,
selbst zu der Zeit, als ich dann schon Regieastant war, habe ich äh am Tag fünfundzwanzig Mack verdient, ne. Sechs Tage in der Woche.
150 Mark Wochenlohn. Und das reichte dann, wenn man äh gut beschäftigt war, reicht es das für die Miete und so?
Und äh auch fürs normale Leben. Aber vorher, Schulgeld und Universität und so was musste ich alles selber bezahlen, klar.
Bafög oder so was gab's ja noch nicht, ne? Also da gab's so ein äh so eine Geschichte, die hieß Honnefer Modell und ich hatte mir die Unterlagen mal äh äh zuschicken lassen,
durchgelesen, das war mir über alles viel zu bürokratisch und da habe ich mir überlegt, ehe ich jetzt äh auflisten muss, wann ich welche Briefmarke wofür gebraucht habe.
Das lasse ich lieber, gehe lieber arbeiten und dann habe ich ja so alle möglichen Jobs gemacht, um
Studiengebühren und Miete und so was zu sagen, weil meine Mutter war schon tot. Mein Vater war ja so ein bissel im Krieg gefallen. Das war neunzehnhundertfünfundvierzig.
Die stand dann plötzlich mit meiner Schwester alleine da und wir mussten uns den Haushalt noch in dieser alten Wohnung, wo wir dann also nach dem
Krieg 1953 eingezogen worden, mussten uns die Miete teilen. Meine Schwester war auch noch in der Ausbildung. Ja und da haben wir uns halt so durchgewurschtelt, muss man auf gut Deutsch sagen. Es reichte so gerade.
Aber das war dann schon eine eine definierte Tätigkeit dann beim beim Fernsehen.
Ja, also ich meine, ich bin ja äh also äh den Weg überhaupt,
in die Medien, im weitesten Sinne, den habe ich ja wirklich über 23 komische Umwege gemacht. Also einmal habe ich ja eben erzählt, war ich im Studio als Diskussionsteilnehmer. Meine Mutter hat das nie gesehen. Wir hatten natürlich keinen Fernseher und es gibt eigentlich nur.
Zeichnung gibt's.
Es war damals live. Das wurde also,
für Jugendliche oder sowas war sowieso nicht wertvoll genug, um es aufzuzeichnen. Also es wurde live gesendet und es gibt also noch zwei Fotos, die irgendein Fotograf gemacht hat, wo man mich da in der Runde mit den anderen Pappnasen sitzen sieht, ne.
Und äh ich hatte,
7zehn, zehn8 hatte ich schon so die die Größe von Meter zweiundachtzig und ein ein äh Klassenkammer hat von mir, der war zu der Zeit schon äh Komparse am Opernhaus
und sagt, hör mal, hast du da nicht auch Lust, hinzugehen und so. Es gibt vier Mark am Abend und das war natürlich richtig viel Geld, vier Mark och ja, habe ich gesagt, ich kann's ja mal versuchen und dann habe ich mich da vorgestellt, mein alter Lokführer, der die,
Führer war, wie das damals hieß.
Erste Frage, sind Sie auch pünktlich? Klar, habe ich gesagt, pünktlich bin ich immer und können Sie auch ohne Brille was auf der Bühne sehen? Sage ich, ja klar, kann ich auch. Also ich kriege den Job.
Und habt ihr nicht, was nicht, wie viel hundert Mal AIDA und äh kamen und also diese großen Opern, wenn Bratspieße in der Hand hintenrum neuen Hut auf nochmal rum oder so erlebt.
Dann hatte ich natürlich so einen Ausweis vom Theater und äh konnte mich da äh relativ frei bewegen, bin dann also eigentlich immer schon
wir müssten eigentlich erst um neun, halb zehn da sein, weil die großen Auftritte waren eigentlich immer erst im letzten Akt oder so. Aber ich bin dann immer schon so um sieben, halb acht hingegangen, habe mich irgendeine Ecke gedrückt und habe geguckt, was machen die da?
Wie geht das mit den Bühnenarbeitern? Was machen die Beleuchter und tötet dann die Sänger sich einsingen als solche Sachen? Und fand also dieses Leben hinter den Kulissen eigentlich ziemlich spannend. Und
da war dann äh so zum ersten Mal das Gefühl, ja das könnte was sein, was mich interessierte.
Aber das war noch eben bevor ich Abitur gemacht hatte und so und dann
als drum ging, was ich studieren wollte, hatte ich mir vorgenommen, also Theaterwissenschaft im Hauptschafft, Hauptfach zu studieren.
Aber meine Mutter, die sagt immer, ach Junge, äh studiert auch was Ordentliches. Dann habe ich ihr zu Liebe noch Germanistik und Philosophie studiert, weil ich damit zur Not noch,
auf Lehramt hätte studieren.
War aber nicht meine äh meine Liebe.
Aber die Liebe war schon das Theater oder was damit verbunden.
Ja, klar, ne? Und dann äh einfach auch der Zusammenhang der des Erlebnis aus dem Studio damals
und die Geschichte mit dem Theater und dann eben auch, dass ich kein Geld hatte, denn ich hatte dann damals nach dem äh Auftritt da den Auftritt und das war so ein ganzes Jahr erging, weil zwei, drei Jahre hat sich mal einen von den Technikern gefragt, wenn ich Abitur hätte, ob ich denn da
mich bewerben könnte, ob's da irgendeinen Job gäbe. Nee, haben die gesagt, da müssen schon Techniker sein oder ein fertiges Studium, aber,
Wir haben äh ein Abkommen mit der Universität, mit dem AStA. Wenn Sie einen Studentenausweis haben, dann können Sie hier als Kabelhilfe arbeiten. Und Kabelhilfe war also nun wirklich der letzte Rasch unter der Sonne.
Das habe ich dann gemacht mit einem frischen Studentenausweis bin ich hin,
und dann äh haben sie mich auch genommen. Dann musste ich erst auf die Bühnenwerkstatt und in den Fundus und äh Ü-Wagen auseinanderbauen und was der tolle Kabel ziehen und so was. Habe dabei viel gelernt.
Toll.
Mir vorstellen.
Und war aber eben auch
90 Pfennig die Stunde zunächst und später gab's dann eine Mark und dann eine Mark zehn und damit konnte ich dann natürlich auch mein Studium finanzieren irgendwo, ne? Da da kam dann Geld rein bei
Bafög habe ich ja gerade gesagt, gab's nicht und und Tonifer Modell wollte ich nicht. Und dann, abgesehen von den anderen Jobs, die ich gemacht habe, ging das dann eigentlich ganz gut. Und so,
lernte ich halt irgendwie
Learning by doing äh Fernsehen von unten kennen, ne? Also Bühnenwerkstatt, Nägel aus den Kulissen ziehen und Funde aufräumen und solche Sachen. Da äh kriegt man schon eine Menge mit.
Übrigens holt uns gerade der der Krieg grade wieder ein, gerade eben,
leuchtet mein Handy auf und äh vermeldet einen Kriegsbombenfund in Köln hier irgendwo. Ja das ist ja ist nicht ungewöhnlich, genau. Man soll sich doch bitte über lokale Medien wie Radio äh informieren. Sehr passend.
Ich hoffe, wenn jetzt nicht gleich abgeräumt hier.
Wo ist es denn, in welchem Stadt.
Das steht hier leider nicht, hier ist nur von ach so doch Rodenkirchen, Rodendorf ist weit weg.
Das weit weg. Rundung, das ist weit weg.
Okay, dann können wir ja weiterreden. Sehr gut.
Ähm dieses Fernsehen damals, ich habe ähm auch mal so ein bisschen in die Geschichte reingelesen, wie sich vor allem das Ganze so ähm inhaltlich,
konstituiert hat, weil es gab ja nichts, was man erst mal aufgreifen konnte. So man muss ja im Prinzip alle Inhalte neu erfinden, ne und äh jetzt hat man so die Technik, dann sitzt man da und kann loslegen und so. Es äh,
muss ich so ein bisschen angefühlt haben als ich meinen ersten Podcast gemacht habe.
Und tatsächlich war das wohl auch so eine ähnliche Situation, dass mal jetzt abgesehen von so Übertragungen, von Konzerten, was ja damals sehr populär war ähm.
Und auch von Theaterstücken.
Genau, also so also erstmal quasi das, was ohnehin öffentlich zelebriert wird in irgendeiner Form mehr in die Weite äh tragen. Macht ja auch Sinn, dass man dann eben aber auch
den Auftrag, den ja letzten Endes das öffentlich-rechtliche Fernsehen von Anfang an hatte, nämlich äh
auch dafür zu sorgen, dass man eben das Ding mit dieser Demokratie äh mal in die Birne kriegt, äh das äh zu unterstützen und
dann war eben auch sehr viel Dialogisches unterwegs. Leute haben sich halt einfach mal vor die Kamera gesetzt und Inhalte so im Dialog äh vermittelt.
Die Zeit war das, ne? Inwiefern hast du denn selber das Fernsehen äh auch wahrgenommen, dass es,
diesem Auftrag nach Alfath und äh versucht zu erfüllen. Also da waren die meisten Leute eigentlich mehr von vornherein auf Entertainment aus.
Wie war da so.
Na so damals gab's ja schon auch eine Reihe von äh sage ich mal durchaus kritischen Sendungen, ne also
ähm ich glaube Panorama ist ziemlich alt und die Nachrichtensendungen, also Tagesschau oder sowas, äh das waren ja auch äh wirklich neue Formate, die man
bis dahin im Radio, klar gab's im Radio auch schon Nachrichten, aber dass das dann mit Bild war und so,
äh ich erinnere mich noch deutlich so äh an die ersten Sachen.
Panorama. Was denn? 61 haben die angefangen. Tatsächlich ist das älteste politische Fernsehmagazin. Mhm.
Aber so Bilder aus der neuen Welt vom Peter von Zahn oder.
Oh ja legendär.
Das waren also die ersten Sachen, an die ich mich erinnere, die ich dann auch nicht zu Hause, sondern irgendwo im Sender mal gesehen habe. Wo also wirklich völlig neue Bilder da waren von äh einer ganz anderen Gesellschaft als die, die wir hier so kannten.
Was die Wohnverhältnisse angeht, was die Landschaft anging, alles das äh das war damals war das sensationell, dass man eben einfach Bilder von irgendwo anders
empfangen konnte und sehen konnte, wie es da zuging oder so was ne und der berichtete ja dann auch, wie das in Amerika ging mit dem Einkaufen und so und mit seiner Familie das war schon äh äh das war schon damals wirklich was Neues, ne.
Und dieses Neue und äh die auch die Notneue heute würde man sagen Formate zu erfinden.
War natürlich einfach auch äh das das Gute und die Chance irgendwas Neues machen zu können oder sich hinzusetzen, zu sagen, was könnte man denn mal machen?
Ne? Und äh damals war's eben nicht so, dass man also dann äh,
irgendwo einfach ins Ausland gereist ist und gesagt, was machen die denn da? Ne, da gab's schon auch Leute, die das gemacht haben, aber es gab eben dann eben auch viele Redaktionen, die hier äh selbstständig sich hingesetzt haben und haben überlegt, was könnte man machen, ne.
Bin ja dann, also ich bin ja erst als Regieastant beim Fernsehspiel gewesen, habe also Fernsehspiele gemacht, äh jede Menge und bin dann auch erst weil ein Fernsehspiel ausfiel
in das damalige Nachmittagsprogramm gekommen, wo's damals aus Jugendprogramm, Frauenprogramm und Kinderprogramm bestand, ne.
Und äh habe dann da, die haben mir dann kontinuierliche Beschäftigungen zugesagt. Das war natürlich wie ein Sechser im Lotto, ne.
In welchem Jahr sind wir jetzt.
Jetzt sind wir schon im Jahr 3undsechzig an 63, 64 in der Kante.
Ich kriegte am 23. Geburtstag kriegte ich zwei Briefe vom Sender und dass ich mich vorstellen könnte als Regieaskant, ich hätte mich schon vorher beworben, aber äh ja,
die Aussicht war gering, weil die schrieben äh ihre Bewerbung liegt unter einem Stapel von 800 gleich lautenden, wenn sie sich wenn der aber abgearbeitet sein sollte, dann greifen wir gerne auf ihre Bewerbung zurück,
hieß im Klartext never ever.
Aber dann habe ich mir ein paar Kumpels hier in Köln den ersten frei produzierten Film mitgemacht ohne Verdienst und äh der der Hanno Brühl, der Vater von dem ähm Brühl, der jetzt ein guter Schauspiel ist von,
vom Daniel, ja. Den Daniel, den kenne ich noch so als winzig kleines äh Würmchen, weil wir mit den Brühls nebeneinander wohnten in
auf der gleichen Etage. Der Vater ist ja leider schon äh mehrere Jahre jetzt tot und äh der hatte mit zwei Kameraleuten äh denn die Idee einen Film zu machen auf 35 Millimeter frei produziert mit
geliehenem Testmaterial und geliehenen Kameras und wir haben den tatsächlich fertig gekriegt und der war zu der Zeit schon Regieassistent beim Sender
und nachdem ich zunächst mal die Absage gekriegt hatte, wir den Film dann fertig gekriegt haben. Wir haben tatsächlich fertig gekriegt, haben ja noch einen westdeutschen Rundflug verkauft und für jeden Blieben dann von uns vier noch haben wir dann äh,
250 Mark übrig, also richtig dicker Batzen Geld damals, ne.
Und der äh ging dann damals zur Frau Merkel, das war die rechte Hand vom Semmelot, der war damals der Leiter vom Hörspiel und Fernsehspiel äh im im Westdeutschen Rundfunk und sagte der,
Also wenn sie mal wieder einen Regieassistenten brauchen, der seinen Arsch mit zwei Händen findet, dann versuchen sie mal den Mai, weil der hat jetzt diese ganze Produktion, die wir da gemacht haben, organisiert. Ich habe das dann organisiert als was weiß ich Mädchen für alles, wie wie immer man das nennen will.
Und dann kam wirklich an meinem 23. Geburtstag zwei Briefe von zwei Abteilungen. Ich könnte mich vorstellen und dann bin ich da hin erst zum Fernsehspiel und dann spätestens habe ich ja grad schon erzählt dann zum äh Nachmittagsprogramm. Und da lernte ich dann
den Gärtner de Ferien kennen. Mit dem zusammen wäre dann diese Geschichte
mit der Sendung, mit der Maus äh ausgekundschaftet, ausge.
Ausgeknobelt haben, wenn man so will. Aber das waren nicht die ersten Geschichten, also zuerst haben wir da gemacht so äh Sachen mit Peter René Körner, der,
Märchenarten auf dem Dachboden oder Liederraten mit Peter René Körner und Kasper und René und solche Sachen und äh das war,
Damals schon ein äh ein Format, dass es bis dahin noch nicht gegeben hatte, nämlich das Handpuppen zusammen mit richtig großen, erwachsenen Leuten spielten, ne und das.
Mhm. So ein bisschen eine Sesamstraße.
Ja aber lange vor der also ich meine in Amerika gab's die Sesamstraße vielleicht schon. Ich weiß nicht. Wir haben die,
bin später mal mit dem äh Gärtner mit den Ferien da bei dem Jim Hans in New York gewesen und äh wir haben dann gesehen, dass die eigentlich in der gleichen Technik spielten wie wir mit den Handpuppen letztlich.
Aber wann die Sesamstraße angefangen hat, weiß ich nicht, weiß bloß noch
der Jim Hansen uns erzählt hat, dass sie das nur machen konnten mit dem Geld der Ford Foundation, weil äh das war dann äh so eine Initiative
gegen die Kinder auf der Straße, die also dann als Spielplatz eben äh die den Mülleimer fanden.
Gar nicht so alt. Also die erste äh Serie von Sesamstraße in USA ist tatsächlich erst Ende 69.
Ja und wir waren glaube ich siebzig bei dem oder so oder sogar schon neunundsechzig, also kann sein ähm
die beiden ja weiß ich nicht mehr ganz genau. Jedenfalls ich weiß, wir haben da eine Rundreise gemacht durch Kanada und und Amerika, um einfach Möglichkeiten auszuloten, ob's irgendeine Möglichkeit gäbe mit Amerikanern irgendwie zusammenzuarbeiten, was sich dann als
völlig unmöglich rausstellte.
Also quasi Mitte der 60er Jahre muss ja dann sehr viel passiert sein. Also Wirtschaftswunder ähm hat sich dann auch so sehr durch die Gesellschaft durchgepflügt, dass es halt einfach auf einmal so ein
eine Mittelklasse in in in Deutschland wieder gab, die sich dann auch in zunehmenden Maße Dinge leisten konnte.
Autos und Fernseher standen da wahrscheinlich relativ weit oben auf der Liste der Begehrlichkeiten und ähm,
Muss es ja irgendwo so einen Kipppunkt gegeben haben fürs Fernsehen, dass man selbst auch gemerkt hat
wir machen jetzt hier nicht nur irgendwie Live-Entertainment für die Upper Class, sondern wir erreichen in gewisser Hinsicht auch einen größeren Teil, vielleicht noch nicht den Großteil, aber äh deutlich größeren Teil der
Gesellschaft.
Kann das so in der Zeit gewesen sein, weil ich meine, wenn in dem Moment, wo man für Kinder äh Programm macht und für Jugendliche muss man ja auch annehmen, dass die die Gelegenheit haben, das auch zu sehen.
Ja äh das gab's ja damals auch schon, ne? Also ich nehme auch an, dass es eigentlich eher in die Fernsehapparate
in den äh Häusern oder Wohnungen der etwas besser verdienenden Leute waren. Aber da gab's natürlich auch Kinder und die konnten natürlich Fernsehen gucken. Und,
Programm für Kinder war er so am als ich anfing hier dreiundsechzig oder so da gab's ja noch so diese äh,
Kinderprogramme, wo dann so ein Haufen Kinder ins Studio eingeladen wurden, die dann also in Sonntagskleidung da saßen und man merkte den an, die waren also
durchaus nicht begeistert von dieser Umgebung, waren also äh völlig gehemmt und die sollten dann äh Lars eine Tante was vor, die die spielten irgendwas zusammen und der Gärtner de Ferien, der sah das und äh hatte das Gefühl, also wir müssen raus ausm Studio, ne. Also wir müssen irgendwie den Kindern die Welt zeigen, wie sie ist.
In der sie leben und äh
Das war aber noch lange nicht so, dass wir dann schon wussten, wie das gehen könnte. Also wir haben mit den Überlegungen dazu angefangen,
äh eigentlich so Mitte der 60erjahre.
Also das äh das erste, raus aus dem Studio war wohl nach dem äh also,
nach Kasper und Rene glaube ich die erste Geschichte, das war so ein Spin-Off letztlich Schlager für Schlappohren mit dem Hasen Caesar. Die habe ich also auch gemacht.
Ah doch äh weil der Hase Caesar der Hase Caesar, wo war denn der nochmal dabei? Den den gab's doch später dann nochmal.
Der Hase C ist aber zunächst eine sage ich mal Nebenfigur beim Märchenraten für Kasper und René,
und der war also der sogenannte mutige Hase, der immer dann, wenn äh wenn ein Fürster auch nur von weitem verschwand der immer, ne und also das der Wolfgang Burich, der den Hasen auf der Hand hatte
war also ein sehr äh guter Puppenspieler und der konnte wahnsinnig gut improvisieren,
dem Gärtner de Ferienfiel das auf und sagt, wir müssen da eine Geschichte machen. Dann haben wir also ein Tonstudio aufgebaut, wo der dann sozusagen als Plattenjocke äh fungierte mit Arno Görke, dem Toningenieur.
Äh die nächste Nummer war dann der Spatz vom Arafplatz. Auch der Spatz, der freche Spatz war auch zunächst mal eine Nebenfigur in diesen äh äh Caspar-und Renégeschichten. Und mit den Spatzen hatte man natürlich die Möglichkeit.
Weil das eben ein Vogel war, blitzschnell den Ort zu wechseln. Er konnte von A nach B fliegen und dann haben wir, ich weiß nicht, auch um die 30 Folgen von gemacht, von dem Spatz vom Marrafplatz. Auch eben an Plätzen, wo man sonst als,
nicht hinkam bei der Feuerwehr oder äh beim Wetteramt oder was der Teufel was äh bei der Bank und äh also an allen möglichen Stellen und
äh dieses Viech, das wohnte also auf der Platane direkt vorm Funkhaus und äh flog dann natürlich auch mal,
ans Fensterbrett vom Intendanten nach dem Motto machst du denn hier oder wir sind auch bei der Sportschau gewesen oder bei Dieter Thomas, der dann das Mittagsmagazin machte und der hat dann immer freche Fragen gestellt.
Stellvertretend für die äh Klientel, also die Kinder, äh um denen zu zeigen, ah, das wird so und so gemacht, ne, also wenn man so will
auch so ein bisschen Medienkunde im weitesten Sinne noch sehr vorsichtig und und äh.
Man tastet sich so ran.
Man tastet sich so ran. Ja und das war aber noch nicht die Sendung mit der Maus, ne. Die kam dann erst.
Ja, ist schon klar. Ich ähm würde ganz gerne nochmal ein bisschen ausloten wie man sich eigentlich so wie so die.
Gesellschaft zu Kindern war damals. So, weil ich meine, heute haben wir so relativ weitreichende.
Zum wie soll ich sagen, so ein es gibt so ein Bild wie Kinder.
Freiheit erleben sollen, die Welt erkunden et cetera.
Ja ja.
Und,
in den 50erjahren und natürlich auch davor waren die Kinder halt irgendwie ja gerade zu kaserniert in den Schulen. Das ist zumindest so mein Eindruck. Also ein sehr viel strengeres äh Regime und
ich habe so den Eindruck, dass es sich in dieser Zeit auch durch diese mediale Vielfalt ein wenig,
das ist dass es begann sich zu lösen. Vielleicht ein bisschen schwer zu umschreiben.
Ja, mit Sicherheit äh ist da was Wahres dran, also es gab ja damals äh noch dieses Verbot für Kinder unter sechs Jahren, die sollten nicht ins Kino gehen, ne und dieses Verbot hat man,
als das Fernsehen denn aufkam, irgendwie eins zu eins aufs Fernsehen übertragen und hat gesagt, also für Kinder soll's eigentlich gar nix geben, ne. Die sollen das noch gar nicht sehen. Bloß die blöden Kinder, die hielten sich nicht dran. Die haben trotzdem.
War ja auch irgendwie interessant.
Natürlicher war's ja was völlig Neues, da in der Wohnung plötzlich irgendwelche Bilder zu sehen von irgendwo her und äh,
es gab ja damals auch schon, das ist äh hängt irgendwie auch mit der mit der Sendung mit der Maus zusammen. Äh dass die Kinder sehr gerne diese Werbespots guckten, ne.
Die konnten also nach dem dritten, vierten Mal, weil die ja auch immer wiederholt wurden
dann saßen die da vor, jetzt kommt der gleich ein Feld auf die Nase oder so und solche Sachen hatten die oder die konnten die die Melodien mit singen, pfeifen, was weiß ich, wie auch immer.
Und äh es hieß ja, dass das Credo war ja, für Kinder muss alles ganz langsam sein. Und diese Werbespots sind ja nun alles andere als langsam.
Damals schon und heute auch. Damals waren die auch relativ schnell
und das schien die Kinder offensichtlich nicht zu überfordern und das war eben auch eine der Gründe, weswegen,
weswegen wir damals, als sie denn so in die Überlegung kam, äh wie könnte denn so eine Sendung aussehen, also was dann später die Sendung mit der Maus wurde äh.
Darf die kurz sein, darf die kurz geschnitten sein, scheint zu funktionieren, weil die Kinder gucken ja die Werbespots.
Gesagt, ja wir versuchen das mal, ne? Und so waren die ersten Filme, die wir gemacht haben, da hieß es noch gar nicht Sendung mit der Maus, sondern es hieß noch äh,
Lach- und Sachgeschichten für Fernsehanfänger und Fernsehanfänger konnten eben damals auch Leute sein
die nicht klein waren, sondern auch Leute, die sich gerade erst einen Fernseher angeschaff.
Das heißt der Begriff ist älter als die Maus selber sozusagen. Mhm.
Und das war also die ersten Versuche waren also eine Geschichte aus dem wirklichen Leben,
Ne, also wir haben damals drei Filme erst mal gemacht, wie wir das eigentlich im Brötchen gemacht, wo kommt die Milch her und wie kommt das Frühstücksei auf den Frühstückstisch?
Und daneben waren dann also Zeichentrickfilme, die gab's ja vorher schon, ne und dann wurde das kombiniert und deswegen hieß es Lach und Sachgeschichten. Die Lachgeschichten waren die Zeichentrickfilme
wo man lachen durfte und die Sachgeschichten waren dann, also die Geschichten, die äh.
Die die Welt erklärten.
Vom Brötchen oder vom so was sagen, ne. Und äh ja, die Maus kam erst später dazu, ne. Die Maus war zunächst mal eine Bilderbuch-Geschichte.
Von.
Wie viele Leute haben sich in diese Lach- und Sachgeschichten gekümmert, also wie groß war das Team.
Drei Leute.
Drei Leute, du und.
Der gärt mit den Ferien und der Siegfried Moorhof. Das waren also die äh Secret-Morph war der äh Abteilungsleiter, der hat Mitte Ferien war der Redakteur und ich war der Regisseur. Wir waren also äh die Test-Crew, wenn man so will, ne.
Wir hatten uns vorgenommen zum Beispiel bei der Milch eben alle Stationen zu zeigen
die die Milch durchläuft, also vom Melken über den Milchwagen, über die Molkerei in Abfüllung, in die,
äh dann in den Laden transportieren und dann erst kaufen und dann in den Kühlschrank und dann nach dem Frühstückstisch und das war natürlich, weil's alles sehr kurz geschnitten war, damals, also für damalige Verhältnisse waren das relativ viele Drehorte.
Also nicht, dass da nur einer stand, das geht so und so und so, sondern wir wollten wirklich zeigen, das sind die Stationen, die die Milch oder das Ei.
Immer am Originalstandort, immer mit dem Originalmaterial.
Ohne zu schön oder sowas. Also war's damals gar nicht so einfach war. Als wir in die Bäckerei kamen und und sagten, wir wollen mal zeigen, wie ein Brötchen gemacht wird, da wurden die erst ihre Bude neu streichen, haben gesagt, nein, nein, nein, um Gottes Willen nicht. Es kam ja das Fernsehen. Es war ja also.
Genau. Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
War ja noch irgendwie was beinahe staatstragendes,
und es hat wirklich Mühe gekostet, den auszureden, die Bude neu zu streichen und die Leute, also den frisch gebügelten Klamotten auftreten zu lassen, also es sollte eben nicht aussehen wie ein Werbespot für ein Brötchen, sondern,
Alltagsgeschichte.
Das echte Leben halt.
Das echte Leben.
Und äh das war schwierig und deswegen war es eben auch damals schon so, wir haben nicht das glückliche Berghuhn aufm Misthof kratzen sehen, sondern es waren damals schon Hühner-Inbatteriehaltung. Ne, also weil wir gesagt haben, wenn das so ist,
müssen wir das so zeigen. Also einfach auch der journalistischen Sorgfaltspflicht geschuldet und.
Damit auch ein perfektes Zeitdokument.
Auch ein perfektes Zeitdokument. Und äh so haben wir uns da rangetastet, aber die waren natürlich diese kurzen Filme durch die vielen Drehorte. Also es bedeutet ja immer, muss irgendwo hinfahren. Licht aufbauen, Kamera aufbauen, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Und das war jetzt auch nicht so kleine Technik wie heute, sondern dicker Apparate.
Ja, war richtig mit Filmkamera, ne und Licht und das Filmmaterial war damals eben noch nicht so empfindlich, wie das dann später wurde.
Worauf wurde da gefilmt?
Auf 16 Millimeter,
Haben wir bis voriges Jahr noch gemacht, ne, auf 16 Millimeter, analog. Digital nachbearbeitet, aber analog gedreht, weil das analoge Filmet hat natürlich eine Standzeit von mindestens 1hundert Jahren.
Die Elektronik überhaupt nicht hat. Ne, also die ganzen elektronischen Nornen, auf denen ich gelernt habe,
im Laufe der Jahre, im Laufe der Jahre sind es sicherlich an die dreißig. Ne, also wenn sich überlegen,
habe noch schneiden gelernt auf zwei Zoll Mats Schwarzweiß. Zwei Zoll so ein breites Band richtig mit einem Fallball wurde das Magnetband durchgeschnitten und mit einer Alufolie hinten beklebt und mit einer Gummirolle festgeklebt und man musste genau den Synchronimpuls für einen Bund äh ein Bild zu Ende war, genau treffen, sonst
das Bild beim beim Abspielen durch,
und da musste man das durch hin und her, musste man das ein bisschen bügeln den Schnitt und wenn es nicht klappte, den Schnitt nochmal machen, rechts ein Bild abschneiden, links ein Bild abschneiden, also ein Mats-Schnitt äh damals war also wirklich.
Schnitt vor allem.
Operation am lebenden Herz wirklich mit weißen Handschuhen und um Gottes Willen nix anfassen und so,
Und danach dann kam äh das war erst zwei Zoll,
Low Band2:0 High Band, dann kam irgendwann äh die Farbe dazu. Dann kam viel später ein Zoll, dann kam ein Dreiviertel-Zoll, diese ganzen Omatik-Dinger, dann äh kam, was weiß ich
Bettamm, dann kam äh Beta kam SB, dann kam äh Diggie Beta und heutzutage liefen wir auf einem Chip ab.
Also mal ganz abgesehen von den äh äh VHS-Normen und was es da sonst noch so alles.
Im professionellen Bereich jetzt keine Rolle gespielt haben, weil's keine große Rolle zumindest.
Ja doch es gab super VHS. Auf denen wurden zum Teil auch so, sage ich mal, Dokumentationen gedreht, ne. Also das gab's schon auch,
und dann dann zwischendurch gab's so Frau Martha wie iMax und weiß det toll was. Also eine unendliche Fülle von äh verschiedenen elektronischen Formaten und ich glaube das wird auch nicht aufhören. Also ähm
Jetzt äh.
Ein bisschen Entwicklungspotential, aber 16 Millimeter Film hat irgendwie auch gut äh den Test der Zeit quasi überstanden. Ja.
Überstanden. Also ich meine, wir haben vor im vorigen Jahr, glaube ich, war's, haben wir diesen ersten Film, den Brötchenfilm neu abgetastet und dann haben wir daneben geschnitten wie heute ein Brötchen gemacht haben, also sozusagen Vergleich gemacht, wie das vor 50 Jahren war.
Mhm. Da ist das Zeitdokument, ja? Mhm.
Und nach der Abtastung sah der Film heutzutage besser aus als damals, ne, weil die Abtastung natürlich besser war,
Zwischenzeit. Klar. Aber natürlich hätten wir damals auf irgendeiner elektronischen Norm gedreht. Also ich habe ja später dann also äh Robbie Toby das Liberty gemacht auf zwei Zoll Mats in Farbe damals, ne. Und wurde
auch am Anfang richtig noch mit der äh mit der Geotine geschnitten
und äh der Alfred Maas, der ist dann ähm mit der ersten Folge, die noch mechanisch geschnitten war, irgendwann um es
Für spätere Generation sinnbar zu halten. Nach Hollywood und hat das Bild verbüllt, dann abtasten lassen da, weil die zweite Folge schon haben wir äh in Bonn
im äh im Studio vom äh in Rodney geschnitten, also weil die äh Studie Bonn war ja
wegen der Aktualität einfach mit der neuesten Technik und da gab's also zum ersten Mal äh Zuspiel, Matz und eine aufnehmende Matz und da konnte man also
per Time Code konnte man also eingeben die äh zuspielende Matzol Abbild 4711,13 oder was?
Also ein automatisierter Schnitt.
Ja also zum ersten Mal, ne, mit einer Zuspielmaschine und einer aufnehmenden Maschine.
Und äh das war natürlich schon ein äh ein ein großer Schritt damals. Aber äh.
Sozusagen das erste Mal gar nicht mehr schneiden musste, sondern man hat das Originalband genommen und nur gesagt, du läufst jetzt von da bis da oder auf dem anderen wird's äh kopiert und der nächste Schnitt von woanders, aber man muss nix mehr durcheinander.
Musste nicht mehr durcheinander bringen, ne. Also musste nicht mehr also tatsächlich und und das war ja am Anfang auch so, wenn man äh irgendwas aufgezeichnet hat auf irgendeiner Maschine, der Kopf, der dieses Band aufgezeichnet hatte,
musste dann bei der Sendung der gleiche sein, weil also diese äh ich weiß nicht, sagt Ihnen irgendwas, diese Schrägaufzeichnung, also diese rotierenden Köpfe damals bei der Zwei-Zoll-Matz,
vier Schlitze, die jeweils um 90 Grad versetzt waren. Und das war natürlich mechanisch, diese exakt neunzig Grad.
Nur bis zu einem gewissen Grad präzise zu machen und der Rest wurde also elektronisch nachjustiert. Das ist also wirklich dann neunzig Grad null null war.
Kalibration, ne.
Ja Kalibation, Kalibrierung, ja.
Die Maschine, die das aufgezeigt hatte, musste natürlich bei der Sendung die gleiche sein, weil da die Kalibrierung die gleiche sein musste, sonst wäre das Bild also permanent irgendwie durchgekippt. Also so war das am Anfang gar nicht so einfach.
So, aber mit 16 Millimeter hatten sie kein Problem. Das ging aufm Abtaster und dann wurde das gesendet und dann der Film blieb ja,
unberührt, also 16 Millimeter hatte lange, lange, lange Zeit einen unglaublichen Vorteil und eben auch,
bis heute sage ich mal, also wir werden wahrscheinlich jetzt in dieser elektronischen Zeit eine geschichtslose Generation werden, weil,
Das, was wir heute aufzeichnen, jeden Tag ändern sich ja die Normen, also wenn sie vor fünf Jahren mit irgendeinem Handy schon mal ein Foto gemacht haben, dann äh können sie es heute, wenn sie's nicht irgendwie übertragen haben aufm Rechner,
auf dem alten Ding schon gar nicht mehr anschauen.
Ist auf jeden Fall gerade eine schwierige schwierige Phase der Übergänge, weil natürlich durch die Innovation immer wieder so sehr viel Neues möglich wird und die Datenformate sich permanent ändern, obwohl ich da auch durchaus sehe, dass sich das in absehbarer Zeit äh konsolidiert.
Hoffen wir mal.
Aber Kevin mal äh wieder zurück in die Bäcker äh Stube und die ersten,
Suche, Sachgeschichten äh zu machen. Also der technische Aufwand war natürlich groß. Man musste viel Equipment machen und äh es war nicht so,
ohne Weiteres jetzt so, dass man so viel Quellmaterial so ohne Weiteres dann auch in einen fertigen Film gießen konnte. Aber es wurde gemacht.
War dann auch verhältnismäßig teuer, ne? Und es gab also dann eine große Diskussion mit der Produktion.
Wollte ich nämlich grade fragen. Inwiefern war denn da.
So teuer sein, das ist doch nur für Kinder und so, ne.
Ja, mhm.
Nur weil also gesagt haben nein wir müssen jetzt was Neues probieren und sich durchgesetzt haben waren diese relativ hohen Produktionskosten äh auch irgendwie durchzusetzen.
Dieses ist doch nur für Kinder. Ich glaube, das ist das, was ich vorhin so meinte, nicht, dass diese Wertschätzung äh gegenüber den Inhalten äh und den Kindern damit ja auch selber vielleicht noch nicht so ausgeprägt war und das.
Hat sich doch bis heute nicht grundsätzlich geändert.
Ist das so?
Ja, ich denke schon, ja. Also zumindest was äh ich meine sie können Millionen für ein Fußballspiel locker machen
aber äh Millionen aufzuwenden für
Filmen, richtigen Fernsehfilm für Kinder, in dem Kinder auch mitspielen. Das ist ja dann auch mit großen Restriktionen. Die dürfen ja nur drei Stunden am Tag arbeiten. Klar, Gewerbeaussichtsam und sowas. Und sie müssen an eine Lehrerin und ich weiß nicht, Sozialpädagogen, was der Teufel ist alles dabei haben.
Alles gut und richtig, aber so ein Film wird natürlich unheimlich teuer, dadurch, dass man also, man hat es ja mal versucht mit Zwillingen. Der eine Zwilling, die Szene probiert und dann kam der andere und wusste natürlich von nichts. Geht natürlich nicht. Klar, solche Sachen. Also,
da die gleiche Menge Geld loszueisen wie für sage ich mal die Fußball-Lizenzen ist ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit,
Haben Sie in den letzten Jahren schon mal einen einen Spielfilm für Kinder gesehen, der hier produziert worden ist? Nein.
Gibt's gar nicht.
Also vielleicht gibt's den ein oder anderen, ich will das den Kollegen nicht Unrecht tun, aber wenn irgendwas da ist, dann ist es meistens äh in Tschechien gemacht.
In Polen oder sonst irgendwo. Also Pantao zum Beispiel, ne, diese auch legendäre Geschichte, die der Gärtner mit den Ferien auch gemacht hat. Ist ja auch in Tschechien entstanden.
Guter äh Punkt darauf wollte ich auf jeden Fall auch noch mal zu sprechen kommen, weil diese Kooperation mit äh Tschechien, die lief ja über viele, viele Jahre, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das äh immer noch ein äh Ding ist. Würde mich mal wirklich interessieren, warum eigentlich,
Tschechien, also Pantao ist äh ein Beispiel, aber nicht das einzige auch, ich glaube der kleine Maulwurf äh war eine tschechische äh Produktion,
Ähm gab glaube ich auch so eine Science-Fiction, die Besucher, weil das nicht auch in irgendeiner Form damit verbunden. Auf jeden Fall es gab eine lebendige.
Und die Rakete gab's, also zum Beispiel, aber ich ob sie ob sie das meinen, weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Auf jeden Fall es gab eine lebendige Fernsehproduktion und eben auch sehr viel ambitioniertes Kinderprogramm in Tschechien.
Und diese Kooperation mit Deutschland ähm die ist ja in irgendeiner Form gab und zwar nicht nur mit Ostdeutschland, wenn ich das richtig sehe, sondern auch mit dem Westen.
Sind da wirklich nur die Inhalte wirklich nur übernommen worden. Gab's da in irgendeiner Form so eine grenzübergreifende Kooperation.
Ja, das gab es wohl, also die äh Kooperation mit äh Pantao zum Beispiel
das war ja schon eine Geschichte, wo also hier die Redaktion auch mit den Leuten, mit den Drehbuchautoren und den Regisseuren da sehr eng zusammengearbeitet haben. Äh weil die Tschechen hatten natürlich auch eine
lange Tradition, ne und bei denen bei den Tschechen war es ja so, das hat mir der Gärtner erzählt, wer da für Kinder arbeitete
musste vorher schon so und so viele Geschichten für,
Erwachsene gemacht haben. Erst dann war er qualifiziert für die Kinder zu arbeiten. Ganz im Gegensatz zu ihr, das ist ja nur für Kinder.
Da war also die Wertschätzung von von Kindern möglicherweise auch aus.
Kulturellen Gründen.
Gesellschaftspolitischen Gründen wichtig. Jedenfalls die Leute, die dann da Pantao zum Beispiel gemacht haben, das waren wirklich
erstklassige Leute vom Kameramann über den Drehbuchautor bis zum Regisseur, bis zu den Musikern, die hatten dann eben auch das große Symphonieorchester von Radio Barrendorf oder so was mit
großem Sound, was hier bei uns gar nicht finanziert werden könnte.
Ne? Und dadurch war natürlich kam hinzu, dass eben die Westwährung da,
als Produktionshilfe gern gesehen wurde ne? Insofern kam das äh ganz gut zustande.
Ich bin äh insofern etwas äh verwundert oder frage mich, wie äh wie das so hat äh kommen können, weil ja natürlich.
Über die Grenze und vor allem halt die nicht nur die jetzt Grenze zwischen zwei Ländern, sondern ja im Prinzip auch die Grenze zwischen zwei Systemen,
ja äh im Prinzip ja auch feindlich äh Gesinnten, Nationen. An der Stelle irgendwie kein Problem zu sein schienen.
Also Kulturleute auf jeder Seite irgendeines merkwürdigen Vorhangs verstehen sich relativ schnell.
Bisschen wie mit Astronauten, ne? Mhm.
Wie mit Astronauten, ne? Also sie können Russen und ein Amerikaner ins gleiche Raumschiff stecken, äh die werden sich da oben nicht die Köppe einkloppen. Ob Heißer Krieg oder Kalter Krieg und so.
Also auch bei den Wissenschaftlern ist das ja so. Und bei den Künstlern erst recht.
Ja, okay.
Und gerade auch die Tschechen, die
ihrem eigenen System durchaus ja äh nicht unkritisch gegenüberstanden. Für die war natürlich eine Zusammenarbeit mit westlichen Leuten auch ein ja,
ein Blick in eine offene Tür oder eine ein ein Schritt über eine offene Schwelle oder wie immer man das ausdrücken will. Jedenfalls es war eine Bereicherung.
Insofern haben die sich beide gegenseitig befruchtet. Also ich meine, ich habe selbst auch später.
In Prag gedreht in der Kooperation mit dem tschechischen äh Fernsehen auf 16 Millimetern, ne. Das war dann also da war die,
Kooperation schon so weit, dass wir allerdings auch noch zu Zeiten des Eisernen Vorhangs. Wir mussten das richtig mit Visum da äh und
äh wir hatten auch immer das Gefühl, dass von den Übersetzerinnen irgendwelche dann von
vom Geheimdienst sein konnten, wie auch immer. Wir wussten's nicht genau. Wir wollten's auch nicht genau wissen. Jedenfalls, es war eine spannende Zusammenarbeit. Ich habe also
kein Wort Tschechisch gesprochen und nur wenige von denen Wort Deutsch, aber wir verstanden uns,
wirklich blind, weil das waren Profis und wir waren Profis. Man brauchte eigentlich bloß auf einen Scheinwerfer zu gucken und dann sagten schon,
Alles gut, ne? Und das erste tschechische Wort, was ich äh gelernt habe, war es Lunze für Sonne, wenn ich auch
auf der Karlsbrücke gedreht und so. Es war spannend. Also auch ähm mit
äh Kollegen, das das war eigentlich immer spannend. Ich habe also was weiß ich mit Tschechien, mit englischen, mit französischen, mit italienischen Teams gedreht, mit schottischen, mit Wasserteufel, was äh
diese Zusammenarbeit mit äh völlig anderen äh Leuten aus fremden Kulturen,
ist immer eine Bereicherung und und äh gibt einem also immer wieder auch einen neuen Blick äh in die Landschaft, in der man sich da bewegt. Man kommt zum Beispiel um was ganz Banales zu sagen.
In Kneipen, die man selber nie finden würde, wenn man mit den Jungs da arbeitet. Dann geht man eben mit denen in deren Stammkneipe und das ist dann wirklich da
wo das wirkliche Leben stattfindet und nicht das, was also irgendwelche touristischen Organisationen einem vorgeben, ne. Das ist also
ein ein unglaublicher Vorteil, ne, wenn man äh kriegt eben dann auch andere Sachen zu essen, die man sonst gar nicht finden würde, weil die einfach sagen, du probieren das. Ist gut oder so, ne, wie auch immer.
Also wir sind ja jetzt so Ende der 60er äh Jahre, Anfang der 70er Jahre und man ich nehme das jetzt auch so ein bisschen so wahr, dass jetzt Kinderfernsehen war jetzt auch so langsam ein eigenes Ding.
Vorher war das so ein Segment und jetzt äh entwickelte es sich langsam auch zum eigenen Genre. Länder wie Tschechien waren da vorne weg,
Gründen auch immer, aber das haben sie auf jeden Fall äh sehr gut gemacht. Pantao fand ich und das reicht jetzt ja auch schon ein bisschen in meine Kindheit mit rein. Das lief ja dann auch äh sehr lange. Waren alles sehr,
äh sehr zauberhafte äh Geschichten, die aber jetzt auch nicht,
nur so in so einem kompletten Fantasieland waren, sondern die aber auch irgendwie auf eine gewisse Art und Weise sehr immer in diese Realität eingeblendet waren, in der man.
Das ist so, ja, ja, ja. Also das Programm für Kinder entwickelte sich
aber eben auch hier beim Westdeutschen Rundfunk sehr sehr stark. Das war also mit eins der stärksten. Äh weil äh der Münzer und der Moorhof einfach immer wieder gesucht haben nach neuen Geschichten, also äh
die haben ja eben auch hier diesen wirklich waghalsigen Versuch gemacht
zu machen wahnsinnige Produktion, ich habe da viereinhalb Jahre dran gearbeitet mit allem drum und dran. Äh mit Puppen auch wieder,
aber mit realen Hintergründen, die dann auf 35 Millimeter gedreht waren und so äh sehr sehr aufwendige Produktion, sehr teure Produktion auch.
Und äh es wurde im Sender geduldet,
aber äh auch wenn der der Münte hat dann auch damals mal mit dem Fernsehspielchef Krach gekriegt
weil er äh wie hieß der Film, äh den er im Ruhrgebiet gemacht hat mit den behinderten Kinder äh vom Max von der Grünen äh
Geschichte, wie hieß das doch noch? Kommen nicht auf den Namen, egal.
Und dann hat der Fernsehspiel gesagt, du Kinderprogramm, ich Fernsehspiel, du nicht in meine Baustelle gehen irgendwie so was, ne? Also das war dann
schon sehr, dass die alle sehr auf ihre eigene Baustelle geachtet haben und also äh wenn der Müntefering also irgendwie,
es zustande gebracht hätte. Den Etat für einen großen Fernsehfilm zusammen zu kratzen, äh die Vorstadtkrokodile war das.
Äh jetzt fällt's mir wieder ein. Äh dann hätte der wirklich Ärger mit dem Fernsehspielchef oder mit der Fernsehdirektion oder so was bekommen, weil die gesagt hätten
das ist nicht eure Baustelle. Da habt ihr die Finger auszuhalten, ne. Insofern mussten wir also immer Formate erfinden, die irgendwo.
Dazwischen passten, ne. Das war natürlich dann auch eine Herausforderung und so,
ist letztlich auch die Maus entstanden als als ein Ding, was zwischen allen Fronten durchlief.
Genau und das war ja dann im Prinzip die Weiterentwicklung dieser Idee, der Lach- und Sach äh Geschichten, kann man so sagen, ne und auch von vornherein so ein bisschen, ich meine, was das ja auch ausdrückt, ist, dass man im Prinzip auf der einen Seite immer Wissen vermittelt, aber auf der anderen Seite auch Spaß.
Dass so Spaß und Wissen.
Nicht ausschließen müssen.
Genau, ganz im Gegenteil, sondern sich in gewisser Hinsicht auch äh ergänzen. Wie kam's denn zur Maus?
Ne, die Maus war erstmal eine Bildergeschichte. Ähm die Ursula Wölfe ist eine Autorin, die Kinderbücher geschrieben hat und die hat äh
damals kam es die Autoren immer in die Redaktion und brachten also ihre Bücher und und sagten
Guckt mal, ist das nicht was für euch oder so was und da waren zwei Geschichten drin, die äh dann äh
im Auftrag an äh Grafiker gingen, die gezeichnet werden sollten, also zu der geschriebenen Geschichte sollten dann also Grafiken gemacht werden. Die wurden dann ganz einfach auf
Pappen aufgenommen diese Zeichnungen und dann von den Pappen mit einer Kamera abgenommen und dann erzählte ein Schauspieler dann die Geschichte, wie sie dann im Buch geschrieben haben. Eine Geschichte war eben die Maus im Laden,
und die kriegte die isolische Mäntel.
Zum Zeugen und die andere Geschichte war die Geschichte vom Fotografen und vom Nilpferd. Und äh die Geschichte vom Fotografen unter dem Nilpferd war so, Fotograf baute immer seine Kamera auf und wollte das Nilpferd fotografieren. Immer wenn er drauf drückt, übers Nilpferd weg.
So
eine witzige Geschichte und die Maus im Laden war eben so nach Feierabend äh schleicht sich eine Maus im Laden in den Laden, riecht Käse und denkt ah lecker, hm dann riechst du aber was anderes, Wurst und und dann na dann wirst du vielleicht noch lecker, dann riechst du gucken bla, bla, bla, bla. Immer so weiter. Jedenfalls
Dass sie immer wieder neue Gerüche wahrnimmt, kann sie sich für nichts entscheiden und ist am nächsten Morgen, wenn der Laden wieder aufmacht, noch genauso hungrig wie am Abend vorher.
Und diese Geschichte hat die isoldische Mitmenzel äh gemahlen.
Illustriert, mhm.
Illustriert mit einer ganz einfachen Maus
ich würde die immer als Kartoffelmaus bezeichnen, weil die also noch sehr grob gezeichnet war eigentlich, aber diese Maus war orange.
Und äh,
diese dieses Orange der Maus war dann später ein äh Riesentheater in einem Urheberrechtsprozess, weil die Maus wie wir sie kennen, die dann animiert wurde
ist eigentlich erst das Verdienst vom Friedrichstreich, der sie zum Leben erweckt hat. Also diese Maus von der Schmidt Menzel war nur einfache Zeichnungen auf Pappkarton.
Dass die Maus sich bewegte und eben dann sich auch drehen konnte und dreidimensional in Anführungszeichen wurde, soweit das eben
beim Zeichentrick möglich ist. Das ist die das ist das Verdienst von Friedrich Streich, der in München war, den kannte wiederum der Moorhof aus einer anderen zusammenarbeiten und sagte
den könnten wir mal versuchen, ob der das schafft und der hat das dann äh gemacht und hat die Maus dann tatsächlich
animiert, also zum Leben erweckt und dann eben auch mit den Geräuschen, also geklappt habe und so was.
Wie kam denn diese Figur, Maus und dieses Konzept Lach und Sachgeschichten überhaupt zusammen? Also was was war ist denn jetzt hier das verbindende Element gewesen?
Das Verbindende Element war, dass diese Maus von Anfang an als sozusagen als stumme Moderator fungieren sollte. Ist ein Gegensatz in sich, weil man.
War eure Idee.
Ja, es war eine äh moderatere plappert ja immer und erzählt, also permanent und die Maus sollte nie reden.
Tut's ihr bis heute nicht. Und die sollte eigentlich nur als Trenner zwischen den einzelnen Geschichten funktionieren. In kurzen, kleinen Spots, die in sich selbst eine abgeschlossene kleine Geschichte darstellen sollten.
Bisschen auch für die Mainzelmännchen. Ich weiß gar nicht, wann die äh dazu kamen.
Ich ich weiß nicht, ob die Mainzelmännchen älter sind als wir. Ich meine.
Ich schau mal nach gute Frage ich glaub kam auch alles in den 70ern irgendwann auf.
Also die die erste Sendung mit der Maus ist im März 71, das gilt ja dann auch als das offizielle Geburtsdatum der Sendung mit der Maus, ne. Gezeichnet wurde aber schon ein Jahr davor. Klar, also bis Zeichentrick fertig ist, das dauert ja immer.
Dreiundsechzig, Mainzelmännchen. Guck an.
Aber das waren die Mainzelmännchen waren sicherlich nicht das Vorbild. Also sondern.
Das wollte ich damit auch gar nicht sagen, aber so diese Idee des Trainers und äh animierte Geschichten und so, weil er ja auch.
Das sollte eigentlich der der Trenner sein, um dann einfach auch mal, wenn man angenommenerweise konzentriert einer Sachgeschichte gefolgt war,
sollte man in dieser kleinen, kurzen Trennungszeit der Maus sollte man einfach die Chance haben, einfach frei zu lachen und sich drüber zu organisieren.
Comic Relief nennt man das heutzutage, glaube ich.
Ist äh es gibt ja für alles mittlerweile irgendwelche Anglizismen, das ist ja zum Kotzen, aber egal.
Ja, wo beschreibt letztlich dieses Phänomen, ne, dass man sich dann auch einfach mal so.
Spannen und dann.
Kann im wahrsten Sinne.
Äh heutzutage sind in einem Haus die, die Maus-Trenner häufig ich sage mal thematisch mit dem vorigen oder dem nachherigen Film irgendwie äh.
Greift es so auf, ne? Ja genau, mhm.
Kommentiert das nochmal, also das war am Anfang gar nicht geplant, sondern es sollte bewusst was völlig anderes sein
und sollte auch mit dem davor oder dem nachfolgenden Film nix zu tun haben, sondern einfach was völlig anderes sein, ne? Und äh war am Anfang auch gar nicht anders möglich, weiß noch gar nicht so viele Spots gab, also ich glaube
die erste Staffel, die der Streich gemacht hat, waren vielleicht fünf oder sechs Mauspots, ne oder so. Weil,
für eine Sekunde Zeichentrickfilm brauchen sie also mindestens 12 einzelne Zeichnungen und die müssen mit der Hand gemacht werden damals.
Auf Folie und äh
erst mit Tusche umrappelt und dann äh mit Farbe ausgefüllt und ich weiß nicht, was alles koloriert und und dann auf einzelnen Folien im Trickfilmatelier dann Bild für Bild aufgenommen werden. Und die Hintergründe dann äh also wir haben dann
was ich auch in den siebziger Jahren glaube ich mal einen Film gemacht, wie der Streich diese Zeichentricks äh Filmchen hergestellt hat.
Das war also eine äh eine wirklich eine Sklavenarbeit, die man also äh das alles zu zeichnen und so mit einer
unglaublichen Akribie, also die Fahrpläne, wo dann wirklich genau definiert war, dieses Bild muss zweimal kopiert werden und der Hintergrund muss sich um was weiß ich, zwei Zentimeter verändern, was da teuer ist, ne? Also,
Fahrplan. Das war also so richtig DIN A4 oder Din A3 Blatt, wo dann also die genau die Bewegungen, die also
A die Maus oder die einzelne Folie äh zu machen hatten, festgelegt waren, ne. Das war also schon
eine Riesennummer, also so ein Zeichentrickding von was weiß ich, dreißig Sekunden oder so was herzustellen.
Klar, heute machen die Computer das mal so mit links und damals war's einfach Handarbeit im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Es war richtige Handarbeit, ne? Und bei dieser äh Geschichte, wo wir in Amerika waren, wo wir dann auch den Jemens und da haben wir auch, waren wir auch bei Walt Disney und die äh saßen dann da ja wirklich
wie am Fließband an langen Tischen hintereinander, also das wäre in Deutschland wäre das unmöglich gewesen, ne. Die hatten grade so viel Platz, dass ihre äh äh Zeichnungen da waren und dann vorher
Platz für den Pinsel und die und das wurde dann wirklich,
Fließband weitergegeben werden. Also einer jetzt, sage ich mal, die Schuhe gemalt hat, bis die Farbe getrocknet war, musste das vier, fünf Plätze weiter sein, dann konnte der nächste erst das Bein malen oder so, ne.
Aber die haben das natürlich mit wahnsinnig vielen äh äh Leuten gemacht. Aber da haben viele eben auch trotz dieser, ich sage mal,
sehr beklemmenden Arbeitsatmosphäre würde ich mal sagen, wenn man die da so in langen äh Reihensitzen sah äh gemacht, weil das eben äh ein Aushängeschild war. Ich habe bei Disney gearbeitet, ne, klar und insofern haben das viele gemacht. Also habe
beim beim Kolorieren oder so, denke ich mal, na wie auch immer, aber das ist nur eine Geschichte, die müssen die Leute, die das machen, selber für sich entscheiden.
Aber so wurde quasi die Maus geboren und hat so ein bisschen ihre eigene Kraft entwickelt.
Dann wurden daraus dann Sendungen gemacht und da hieß es auch schon, die Sendung mit der Maus. Weil es war ja die Maus dabei, also Lach und Sachgeschichten, als solche gab's dann quasi nicht mehr so ein direkter Übergang gewesen oder.
Nee, das wird es wurde dann äh das war dann also als die Maus dann dabei war, ne. Dann äh ähm zum ersten Mal hieß ich glaube die erste Sendung hieß auch immer noch,
Lach und Sachgeschichten, ne? Und dann schrieben die Kinder ich habe die Sendung mit der Maus gesehen und äh ich erinnere mich noch
deutlich, wie der Müntefering wäre ein sehr äh auch ich würde heute sagen hektisch, also der war immer auf auf Tour von einem Büro ins andere und sauste immer hin und her und irgendwie aufm Gang sagt er,
Alle reden von dem aus. Ich weiß, wie wir das nennen. Wir nennen das einfach die Sendung mit der Maus. Punkt. So ist der Titel entstanden aufm Gang. Äh reiner Zufall.
So und dann so hieß dann die Sendung mit der Maus, ne.
Im Prinzip ähm auf Feedback äh reagiert, würde man das heutzutage nennen.
Ja? Also ich wollte eh grad fragen diese Popularitäts ähm Messung, ja, die ja später dann mit Umfragen und welchem Aufwand äh alles getrieben wird.
GFK, ja.
Das gab's zu dem Zeitpunkt so noch nicht, oder?
Gab's schon auch. Es gab auch schon damals die die Quote, die heute ja die Heiligste allerheiligen Kühe ist,
Und die Werte, die konnte man damals auch schon sehen und dann in ich erinnere mich an der Redaktion, er hieß ja, heute war ZDF besser als wir, ne? Morgen sind wir dann wieder besser, egal.
Wie viel Uhr lief die Maus damals.
Äh zunächst mal,
im Nachmittagsprogramm und äh das war dann ja auch so, dass äh die Sonntagstermine von den einzelnen Senderanstalten natürlich,
gehütet wurden wie äh der Gral. Also jede Sendeanstalt hatte äh analog zu ihren
Zuschauern, also eine Menge ihrer Zuschauer auch. Die einen hatten zwei Sonntage, die andere hatten zehn Sonntage, die andere hatten vier Sonntage, ne, je nachdem äh ob du hessischer oder Bayerischer oder
Radio Bremen wie auch.
Halt, ja.
Irgendwann hat der Gärtner und der gesagt, ja wir haben jetzt so eine äh Strecke, wo wir mal sechs Sonntage hintereinander haben oder so was und dann haben die sich zum ersten Mal auf den Sonntag gesetzt.
Also es gab die Maus einmal die Woche.
Einmal die Woche, ja,
Und äh sie wollten's also bewusst jetzt mal auf dem gleichen Sendeplatz in einer gewissen Kontinuität laufen lassen, um einfach,
bei den Zuschauern auch sich festzusetzen und zu sagen, da gibt es etwas, das immer zur gleichen Zeit kommt.
Der Sonntag war natürlich ideal und heilig in dieser Hinsicht, weil die Leute Zeit hatten, ne?
Ich glaube der die die Termine waren am Anfang um halb zehn morgens so und da gab's natürlich sofort Krach von den Kirchen. Ihr hindert die Kinder dadran in den Kindergottesdienst zu gehen, ja,
klar ne also es gab ja nichts und niemanden der sich nicht irgendwie bemüßigt fühlte da äh.
Über irgendwas aufzuregen, ja.
Sich über irgendwas auch. Das ist besäute so. Jedenfalls dann hatte sich das so ein bisschen äh festgesetzt und aber
dann äh stieg noch ein anderer Sender mit ein. Äh ich glaube der saarländische Union war der Erste, der mit einschlägt, dann kriegte man die zwei Sonntage noch dazu.
Äh gab's zwischendurch auch mal der Hessische Rundfunk, hat auch mal mitgemacht. Ich glaube auch Radio Bremen und so und der Südwestrundfunk äh wie auch immer äh es
addierte sich dann, dass es also zunächst, ich war mal sechs Sonntage waren, dann waren's irgendwann mal zehn, dann waren's mal zwölf, aber bis es zum ARD-Modell wurde, dass man also das zweiundfünfzig Wochenende äh
im Jahr aufm Sonntag sind. Das hat eine ganze Weile gedauert. Wann genau das war, weiß ich nicht mehr so genau.
Irgendwann in den 70ern doch.
Es könnte sein, dass das sogar erst in den 80ern gewesen ist.
Bin nicht sicher, wann das wöchentlich war und dann äh wurde es verlegt.
Aber die Quote war gut.
Ja, offensichtlich, ja, sonst hätten die anderen da nicht zugestimmt. Und äh dann wurde es irgendwann,
nach halb zwölf verlegt, damit eben diese Kindergottesdienstzeit äh außen vor war.
Und das halb zwölf war dann lange Zeit, nachdem es ARD-Modell war, äh dann kriegten wir sogar eine Nullzeit. Das bedeutet,
dieser Sendetermin durfte ohne triftigen Grund nicht aufgegeben werden. Also genau vor dem Presseclub, ne? Also wir waren unmittelbar vor dem Presseclub immer.
Und äh das ist so lange gegangen, bis das ZDF irgendwann mit seinem Fernsehgarten ankam und dann
schrien wohl die
ARD Oberen. Oh, da ist im ZDF ist jetzt Fernsehgarten, da gehen alle Zuschauer hin und wir mit der Maus können dagegen nicht anstinken und so. Dann wurde es wiederverlegt und dann hat äh da will er auch die ARD, wer auch immer das war, dann haben die ja auch so ein Sonntagsformat dagegen gesetzt, irgend so ein
Jubel, Trubel, Heiserkeit Ding. Äh.
Und äh die Maus musste natürlich weichen. Also ich meine äh so viel zum Stellenwert von Kinderprogramm, ne. Also auch wenn es etabliert war, muss es dennoch weichen.
Klar.
Trotzdem hat sich die Sendung schon ein Standing erarbeitet und das hat auch ja.
Im Laufe der Zeit ja, ja.
So einen Kipppunkt. Das ist das ist irgendwie so anerkannte populäre Kultur war.
Keine Ahnung, wann es.
Schwierig das von innen herauszufühlen, ne.
Eine Schwierigkeit, das auch zu definieren, glaube ich, ne. Äh was passierte war natürlich,
je populärer die Sendung wurde, desto mehr kam eben auch Fragen von Kindern oder so. Es ist ja bis heute so. Also ähm wir kriegen in einer Woche so zwischen tausend und zweitausend Zuschriften, ne. Das ist eine eine ganze Menge.
Äh auf E-Mails auf weißer Teufel, was auf Packpapier auf Kerten früher natürlich meistens mit geballten gemalten Bilderchen oder sowas und
die äh schrieben dann eben auch,
mach doch mal etwas über das und das fingen also an Fragen zu stellen oder Wünsche zu äußern äh für Inhalte oder so was ne und eben auch
dass die nicht nur sagen, wie wird denn das und das gemacht, sondern auch wie funktioniert denn das und das. Sodass wir also auch im Laufe der Zeit äh
weg von den rein Sachgeschichtenthemen zum Beispiel wird ein Streichholz gemacht
eine Reißzwecke gemacht hin zu den Dingen, wie funktioniert das, ne? Wie funktioniert äh was weiß ich?
Zum Beispiel im Kühlschrank oder äh später natürlich, wie funktioniert das im Internet? Was passiert, wenn ich auf den Buchstaben A drücke? Solche Sachen.
Absolut legendär die Erklärung, wie äh Internetadressen aufgelöst werden
äh wo sie auch nochmal äh für die komplette Hackerszene äh Deutschlands sprechen, die einfach das gefeiert hat bis zum Get Now, das war so großartig, weil's so schwierig war irgendwie diese Sachverhalte zu erläutern und,
über diese.
Diese Mausmethode, wie ich's jetzt mal nennen möchte, über die wir nochmal sprechen müssen, die die hat es irgendwie auf so eine natürliche Art und Weise geschafft, das auch alles so abstrakt
äh herunterzubrechen, das ist einfach auf eine natürliche Art und Weise klar wurde und äh das ging sogar bis dahin.
Die Elektronik ist natürlich ein Ding, was man nicht sieht. Geht ja schon beim blöden Strom los, ne? Sie können Strom nicht sehen. Sie können aufn Lichtschalter drücken, geht die Lampe an oder aus. Klar.
Man sieht also nur die Auswirkung von Strom und das ist ja nun noch ganz banal gemessen an dem, was auf so einem Chip oder so was passiert oder in einem Rechner. Und die Schwierigkeit lag also da drin, gerade jetzt bei dieser Internetgeschichte.
Bilder zu finden oder Analogien zu finden, die da in Bruchteilen von Sekunden
in blitzes Schnelle passieren und aber eben um klarzumachen, da muss erst das passieren, damit das und das passieren kann, damit das dann als Folge dessen wiederum passiert. Und das aufzudröseln, das ist sicherlich auch eins der sage ich mal,
Erfolgsgeheimnisse der Sendung mit der Maus, dass wir also komplizierte Sachverhalte,
aufdröseln können und versuchen, das in kleinen Schritten Stückchen für Stückchen zu lösen. Erst passiert das und dann passiert das. Wobei das natürlich auch äh schwierig ist.
Rechner passiert ja alles mehr oder weniger gleichzeitig. Da sind also der Unterschied in Nanosekunden, das kann man ja äh,
fast gar nicht messen. Also muss sagen, es passiert gleichzeitig. Die drücken aufn Knopf und im gleichen Moment ist aufm Bildschirm schon alles da, was sie gerade gemacht haben.
Aber,
trotzdem ist es ja ein langer Prozess wie bei vielen anderen Dingen und da muss man dann erst sagen, okay, da wird also erst der Kontrolle ausgeschaltet und bla, bla, bla. Also die sind gar nicht ich habe nicht mehr im Kopf, den Film ist ja auch egal.
Und das.
Bezog mich jetzt gerade konkret auf diese äh Sache wie das Web funktioniert,
Auflösen von IP-Adressen, wo äh da nicht immer quer durch das ganze Gebäude äh lief und immer jemand irgendwelche fragen musste, um irgendwie irgendeinen Namen, eine Adresse umzusetzen, bis dann die Mausseite kam. Das war einfach ganz verzüglich.
Das war auch eine eine schwierige Produktion, dass auch aufzudröseln und äh ich glaube, wir haben da eben auch jede Menge Leute irgendwelche Löcher in den Bauch gefragt, um das auch erst mal selbst zu kapieren, was passiert denn da drin?
Mhm. Offensichtlich die richtigen, weil ich äh kann mich noch gut an die Zeit erinnern. Der Rest der Medienlandschaft hat es äh für sich äh kaum aufgedröselt bekommen.
Also das ist eigentlich immer die Frage bei bei jedem Ding, was auf uns zukommt. Erst mal jemanden finden, der da so Bescheid weiß,
Löcher in den Bauch zu fragen. Wir sagen immer so lange zu fragen, bis der Arzt kommt.
Äh dann ist das aber noch lange keine Geschichte. Ne, also wenn man einfach nur die Fakten aneinander klatscht.
Langweilig werden.
Ist das langweilig, ne? Das heißt, man muss dann einen Weg finden, daraus eine Geschichte zu machen, die möglichst nicht langweilig ist, also denn,
langweilig ist, dann äh schalten die Zuschauer auch groß oder klein, schalten die ab und das sind natürlich die schlechtesten Zuschauer, die abschalten und das wollen wir natürlich vermeiden.
Insofern ist dann immer also der erste schwierige Schritt ist die Recherche. Die dauert meist ziemlich lange.
Bis man die Geschichte so sehr selbst begriffen hat, dass man damit was anfangen kann. Äh dann kommt der zweite schwierige Schritt, okay, was machen wir jetzt daraus? Wie kann man diese einzelnen Schritte denn jetzt,
visualisieren, möglichst mit Dingen, die jedes Kind kennt. Also mit kochendem Wasser oder mit Spaghetti oder meinetwegen mit Legosteinen oder mit
Dingen, die sogenanntes sprichwörtliche Kind von Küche, Haus und Keller kennt, also.
Des Alltags halt.
Dinge des Alters, wo keine Verständnisbarrieren zu überbrücken sind, also Computeranimationen oder Schemazeichen oder so was, mit denen man alles belügen oder beweisen kann, sind im Prinzip bei uns tabu.
Ne, das heißt, wir vertrauen nach wie vor der Wahrheit der realen Bilder. Also äh dessen, was man irgendwie,
anfassen kann. Was haptisch ist. Und äh im besten Fall,
sogar so, dass man es zu Hause unter Umständen nachmachen kann und äh vielleicht nachbauen oder weiß der Teufel was, ne? Oder zumindest Verständnis dafür entwickeln kann, ne.
Und das dann so zu bauen, dass daraus eine Geschichte wird.
Das war aber nicht von ganz Anfang an so, ne? Also die allererste äh Sendung mit der Maus waren so, das musste sich auch noch ein, zwei Jahre konzeptionell in das verwandeln, was es später.
Ja, natürlich, klar, also auch unsere ersten äh Geschichten, die wir gemacht haben, also Brötchen, Milch und Ei, äh da haben wir einen einen Denkfehler gemacht.
Und zwar äh uns war klar, es sollte ohne Kommentar sein, also ohne Text
ersten Geschichten und wir wollten die Geschichte rückwärts erzählen. Also wir haben auf dem Frühstückstisch angefangen, ne? Ist also das Brötchen. Davor war es, was weiß ich, in der Brötchen-Tüte, die der Bäckerjunge gebracht hat, davor wurde es eingebaut
davor wurde es aus dem Ofen gezogen, davor wurde das und so weiter und so weiter. Rückwärts bis zum Mehl im im Topf, der also dann mit Wasser und Wasser angerührt wurde.
Um aber trotzdem eine Art Orientierung zu geben, haben wir die einzelnen Stationen mit Zahlen versehen. Also zwölf war der Frühstückstisch, elf war mal der Brötchenjunge, zehn war das Einpacken und so weiter bis zu null und null war dann das Ding. Und dabei hatten wir den Fehler gemacht
Als Kinder, die vielleicht noch nicht schreiben konnten, vielleicht auch noch nicht zählen konnten. Und äh das war natürlich auch eine der Kritik
Punkte, die viele Leute dann äh uns um die Ohren geschlagen haben. Abgesehen von viel zu schnell.
Der Gärtnete Ferien ist dann eben auch mit den ersten Filmen so durch Kindergärten und so was gezogen und hat also dann einfach die Leute gefragt, wie finden sie das denn und ist das was oder so? Und kriegt es rechts und links um die Ohren und und äh kam also ganz geknickt
zurück und sagte ja
Vielleicht nochmal ein zweites Mal versuchen und ähm ja vielleicht haben sie auch an der einen oder anderen Stelle recht. Vielleicht muss man an dem einen oder anderen.
Der Geschichte ein Stichwort geben, damit man eben weiß, wodrauf man achten soll. Also man sieht ja nur das, was man sehen soll.
Da haben wir nochmal drei gemacht. Einer davon war äh eine Autobahn soll gebaut werden und der Anstreicher kommt, also so, ne. Es waren ganz langsam geschnittene Filme. Also das Gegenteil vom Brötchen, Milch und Ei.
Unendlich lange Einstellung, unendlich langsam und manchmal eben auch ein Satz, der erste Satz, der jemals in einem ausgefallen ist, war hier soll eine Autobahn gebaut werden.
Man also die Leute sah die also mit so einem Ding dann äh den den Boden abtasteten. Ja und äh.
Das waren also die schlechtesten Filme, die ich je gemacht habe und
äh ich sage immer, wenn man in der Hölle ist und kriegt also die ganzen schlechten Filme seines Lebens um die Ohren, laufen die als Dauerschleife, wie auch immer.
Das war's also auch nicht. Die haben wir dann auch angeguckt. Also so kann's auch nicht sein. Also das ist nicht die Lösung, es langsam zu machen. Das ist ja sowas von quälend, langsam und auch langweilig und man hört es denn endlich auf und gesagt, okay, wir müssen wieder schneller werden.
Und dann, ich glaube, im dritten oder vierten Versuch haben wir dann äh mit Gabellöffel Schuhstuhl
noch einer war dabei. Dann die Form gefunden
Dass wir also bei industriellen Prozessen, wo man da so in der Maschine nicht genau sehen konnte, was da passierte, also nach dem Stanzen haben wir dann das Stanzprodukt noch mal rausgenommen und extra fotografiert und sagen, so sieht das jetzt aus.
Und das war dann eigentlich der Punkt, wo das.
Umkippte, wo das langsam akzeptiert wurde, dass man also solche Geschichten machen konnte. Und es entwickelte sich weiter als zunächst bei äh industriellen Produktionen.
Und als dann die Frage kam, wie funktioniert das denn? Da musste man natürlich wieder einen ganz anderen äh Bogen finden, um das zu erzählen.
Richtig verstehe war so ein bisschen die die ersten Lehren waren so also rückwärts erzählen war wahrscheinlich sowieso schon mal eine schlechte Idee,
Zahlen sind schon viel zu kompliziert. Es erklärt sich quasi nicht von von alleine und schließt auch gleich wieder welche aus. Man muss den richtigen Rhythmus finden
die richtigen Geschwindigkeit finden und das ist halt weder zu schnell noch
zu langsam. Klar, es gilt ja eigentlich für alles, aber so so ein gewisses Stakkato kann man schon machen, vor allem wenn's eben chronologisch ist und wenn man wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe, äh weiß ich, gilt das mit diesem Stichwort noch, also muss es etwas geben, was man immer mit
denkt, was ähm oder was von dem einen aufs nächste überleitet, was äh oder war das dann auch nur ein.
Im Laufe der Zeit hat sich natürlich äh die Text äh Linie deutlich vergrößert. Also heutzutage werden die Geschichten ja mehr oder weniger durcherzählt.
Am Anfang gab's gar keinen Kommentar, da sollte das Bild quasi nur für sich selber sprechen.
Also unser Vorbild waren die alten Stummfilme, die ja nur in Bildern erzählt, ne. Das war unser Vorbild. Also äh wo dann immer zwischendurch ein Plakat war äh August liebt Emma oder so was.
Ja ja.
Und so hatten wir auch diese Zahlen verstanden, die also dann dazwischen sein sollten. Das hat offensichtlich nicht funktioniert. Und dann das nächste war eben
mit Stichworten versehen und dann würden's immer mehr Stichworte, dann kamen halt plötzlich ein ganzer Satz. Dann wurden's zwei Sätze und so weiter und so weiter und so weiter und mittlerweile ist es dann also richtig durcherzählt.
Genau. Und das hat sich dann ja eigentlich auch als Erfolgsmodell eigentlich durchgesetzt, weil so dieses Geschichtenerzählen ich meine,
Und das ist ja in also in meiner Wahrnehmung, was ich vorhin angesprochen hatte, so dieser dieser Durchbruch der Popularisierung der Maus
weit über. Das ist jetzt einfach nur eine Kinderfernsehsendung, die viele kennen zu dass das ähm ja geradezu auch schon so zu so einem deutschen Kulturgut
geworden ist. Das habe ich so bisschen daran festgemacht, dass eben dieser Stil auch in zahlreichen anderen.
Dingen kopiert wurde und dass so diese Erzählgeschichte und dieser Tonfall auch eben damit auch diese Geschwindigkeit, die das ja intrinsisch mit drin hat, dass das sozusagen von allen erkannt und akzeptiert wurde als so ein,
Das war einfach die Maus.
Es ist halt so, ich meine äh wenn ich die Geschichten erzähle, also wenn ich sie selber mache, die sind niemals aufgeschrieben. So ich habe nie einen geschriebenen Text vor mir, sondern ich erzähle die zum laufenden Bild. Ich sage immer, mein Text steht in den Perforationslöchern.
Es ist so man schneidet eine Geschichte.
Dann überlegt man sich beim Schneiden natürlich, was muss man dazu sagen und probiert das auch, trocken im Schneidet,
und dann ist das Ding irgendwann fertig, ist abgenommen, dann kommt sie ins Tonstudio und äh dann äh.
Merkt man, oh, da ist ja noch ein eine halbe Sekunde oder so halt kann ich noch einen Blödsinn draus machen oder so oder,
das Ding noch ein bisschen anders drehen oder so. Sodass einfach in dem Moment, wo das erzählt wird, noch mal eine neue ich sage mal.
Ich will's nicht Qualität nennen, aber eine neue Stimmung aufkommt und so und das macht das Ganze dann irgendwo lebendig.
Und eben auch so, dass man wirklich das Gefühl hat, das erzählt jemand. Da liest nicht jemand irgendeinen Text ab und äh,
betet da was runter oder so was. Sondern es wird wirklich
erzählt und man nimmt dann eben auch bewusst äh vom Bild auf und so. Ihr müsst da oben links in der Ecke gucken oder sowas, ne? Manchmal um auch den Blick zu lenken bei Bildern, wo man dann äh nicht auf den ersten Blick weiß, aha,
es hat heutzutage ja bei diesen komplizierten äh äh,
Produktionsmaschinen, wo man also dann gar nicht weiß, worum's man denn hingucken. Da muss man den Blick manchmal lenken. Also ihr müsst jetzt genau da hingucken, weil da passiert.
Das kleine schwarze Ding da links oben.
Genau, genau. Irgendwie sowas, ja. Und das ist natürlich dann auch eine äh eine Geschichte, die äh die sich erst beim,
Erzählen ergibt, ne? Und ähm das haben wir dann aber auch erst ich sage mal, gelernt.
Ne, im im Laufe der Zeit, dass das also ein guter Punkt ist, aber
zur Frage des allgemeinen Kulturgutes. Es ist ja mittlerweile so, dass es also mindestens genauso viele Erwachsene sind wie wie Kinder, die zuschauen. Weil wir haben natürlich auch
Waschkörbe voll von Briefen von Erwachsenen, die dann schreiben. Also endlich habe ich mal begriffen, wie das und das geht, was ich vorher nie begriffen habe und in der Schule nie gelernt habe oder so was, ne.
So eine Erfahrung, die man macht, wenn man äh Kinder hat so. Dann kriegt man halt so diese Fragen gestellt so, ja wie funktioniert denn das eigentlich und stellst du fest so ja hm keine Ahnung.
Oder warum ist das so, ne.
Mir noch nie so richtig Gedanken drüber gemacht, weil man dann doch vieles einfach erstmal nur so,
wie sie sind und dann, keine Ahnung, nie drüber nachgedacht hat und dann lebt man sein Leben und äh vielleicht ist ist es auch eine vollkommen falsche Vorstellung davon, wie irgendetwa
was funktioniert und da war dann die Maus und natürlich auch so spätere Formate, wie Wissen macht A finde ich haben einfach einen extremen ähm.
So ein so ein so eine Lexikalische Aufgabe in gewisser Hinsicht auch schon übernommen, ne? Das ist also ein bisschen so Video-Lexikon so. Ja, mal schnell erklären lassen und wenn man sich heute anschaut, was im Internet populär ist,
Ja, also die ganzen YouTube-Kanäle, die halt eigentlich auch in kurzen Geschichten,
bestimmte Dinge beschreiben, auch technische Vorgänge, alles Mögliche und auch das ist ja sehr populär.
Ja, ja, ja klar. Also.
Also ich würde mal fast sagen, die Sendung mit der Maus hat quasi YouTube vorher gesagt.
Kann schon sein. Das kann schon sein, vielleicht, ja? Könnte sein, also wo war ich hängengeblieben bei den bei den Erwachsenen, die dann,
also äh das auch sagen und da ist es dann natürlich so, äh dass mittlerweile das die dritte oder vierte Generation ist, also
Leute, die früher als Kind die Maus geguckt haben, gucken uns dann mit ihren Kindern und mittlerweile die Großeltern mit ihren Enkeln, ne. Das ist also äh so ein,
offensichtlich durchgehender Faden, wo man natürlich sagen kann, das ist natürlich nicht ganz schlecht, wenn sich das so über die Zeiten äh als eine Qualitätsmerkmal äh gehalten hat. Nicht schlecht.
So, jetzt läuft diese Sendung seit fünfzig Jahren. So, du machst das ja irgendwie auch echt schon von Anfang an. Ähm warum ist es nicht langweilig geworden?
Weil jede neue Geschichte eine neue Geschichte ist und bei jeder neuen Frage stehst du wieder wie der Ochseform Scheunentor oder sonst irgend einer sagt,
Ach, das ist ja ein Ding. Das ist ja eine Frage.
Kinder stellen die Fragen. Erwachsene äh gehen dann bei so Unterhaltung, wenn man irgendwo ist auf einer Feier und so machen alle ein schlaues Gesicht, so nach dem Motto, ja, das weiß man doch. Und wenn man dahinter schaut, weiß man es eben nicht.
Aber äh man traut es sich nicht zu sagen, weil man sich nicht äh das Image eines ungebildeten Menschen,
geben will und Kinder sind da völlig unbefangen. Die fragen einfach. Ihnen fällt irgendwas auf.
Wer nicht fragt, bleibt dumm.
Stellen die Frage und die sind zum Teil eben so da kommt ein Erwachsener gar nicht mehr drauf, weil der schon so
verbildet ist oder so sehr in seinem Schema drin ja das musst du doch als Erwachsener eigentlich wissen. Das darf man sich doch gar nicht mehr zu fragen trauen,
oder so. Unsere wenn fragen die das nicht, aber manchmal haben wir auch das Gefühl, dass die Eltern ihre Kinder vorschicken und zu sagen, fragt doch mal das und das nach. Weil sie's selbst auch nicht wissen, wie auch immer.
Da äh sind die die seltensten Geschichten und die merkwürdigsten Geschichten sind da.
Ist mir schon klar, wenn man halt immer wieder an solchen Sachen arbeitet, das ist natürlich spannend, aber das Format als solches, also,
ich nenn's mal so die Maus-Methode, die er da so entwickelt hat. Hat die sich noch groß geändert? Also hat sich die Sendung
selbst über die Zeit auch noch geändert oder ist es tatsächlich dieses nach wenigen Jahren eine gefundene Grundmodell, was irgendwie die Zeit auch überdauert hat.
Also das Grundmodell, was sich sicherlich nicht verändert hat, ist die genaue Recherche.
Das genaue Nachbohren, was steckt denn dahinter? Also eigentlich auch ein journalistischer Grundsatz, ne. Wir sind nichts und niemandem verantwortlich, außer der Wahrheit. Äh so gut wir sie denn rauskriegen können.
Auch schon mal Fehler, die korrigieren wir dann aber auch, aber verändert hat sich natürlich die Sehgeschwindigkeit ganz klar.
Schnitte sind kürzer geworden im Laufe der Zeit. Die Themen haben sich verändert. Natürlich auch deswegen
weil moderne Kinder, also ich sage mal Kinder, die heute leben, andere Fragen stellen als Kinder vor 20 oder vor 30 Jahren. Vor 30 Jahren hätte man die Frage
Woher weiß das Telefon, dass ich jetzt auf der Domplatte bin, äh noch gar nicht stellen können, weiß da gar noch kein Handy oder so was gab
So. Äh und,
So verändern sich natürlich auch mit zunehmendem Leben die Fragen, die die Kinder stellen, weil jedes Kind,
Natürlich seine Welt für sich neu, wobei dann natürlich immer wieder auch die gleichen Fragen kommen. Warum ist der Himmel blau?
Frage wurde vor 30 Jahren schon gestellt, deshalb aber ich war vor 20 Jahren schon mal beantwortet, kommt aber immer wieder, weil jedes neue Kind in den Himmel guckt und sagt, warum ist denn der blau?
Ist die Milch weiß oder solche Sachen. Es gab mal
was ich vor vielen Jahren so 'ne Geschichte wenn ihr mal 'ne Frage habt dann schreibt das doch mal auf und schreibt euch was interessiert und dann kam dann innerhalb von einer Woche, ich weiß nicht äh,
70.000 oder über 70.000 Fragen. Das war in der kleinsten Computerschrift so ein Bündelpapier.
Wenn wir das abarbeiten wollten, äh dann sind wir noch bis zum Jahr 219 beschäftigt. Die zehn meist gestellten Fragen haben wir damals rausgefiltert und haben die beantwortet. Da war eben auch
Der blaue Himmel dabei und das durchsichtige Wasser und die weiße Milch und solche Sachen. Aber äh es kommen halt immer wieder auch neue Fragen, ne.
Jetzt natürlich mit äh wie wird ein Computerspiel gemacht? Wie wird dies gemacht? Wie wird das gemacht? Ne, also alles Dinge aus dem äh.
Umfeld der Kinder, wie sie jetzt leben.
Dieses.
Klären, komplexer Zusammenhänge auf eine lustige Art und Weise, ist ja auch von anderen noch aufgegriffen worden. Ähm ich denke, hier muss man vor allem,
Löwenzahn nennen wir Peter Lustig. Gab's da eine unmittelbare Verbindung oder lief das so.
Lustig war er am Anfang bei der Maus. Der hatte.
Anfang eine eigene Kategorie Peter und Atze. Atze war so ein gezeichnetes Viech und eine Peter Lustig. Der war ja eigentlich ursprünglich Toningenieur, ich glaube.
SFB oder Rias, also bei einem äh der der frühen Berliner Sender, ich glaube Rias könnte es gewesen sein und der der Peter konnte wirklich gut erklären hm.
ARF-In und dann SFB. Hm.
Na gut, also elf ändern, ne? Wie auch immer. Äh jedenfalls äh.
Mit seiner Kategorie Peter und Atze war aber viel mehr für ihn hier nicht drin beim Westdeutschen Rundfunk, weil es eben auch nur ein Baustein in dieser Maus,
sage ich mal, Philosophie war. Also das da ganz unterschiedliche Sachen zusammengepackt werden sollten.
Das war so ein Vogel, ne? Ja. Mhm. Roboter.
Und dann bekam er wohl vom ZDF den äh äh den äh die Möglichkeit, da eine eigene Sendung zu machen und dann war eben der,
Bitter, der mit dem Latz, mit der Latzhose und dem Bauwagen und der hat sich ja dann ausschließlich um ökologische Themen mehr oder weniger gekümmert.
Mehr oder weniger, ne. Der war also nicht so bunt, wie wir das waren. Also wir gucken nach da und wir gucken in eine ganz andere Richtung. Wir gucken nach vorne. Wir gucken nach hinten. Peter hatte ja immer dann seine Einheit mehr oder weniger von seinem Bauwagen und
da rund rum passierte was und da dran hatte er seine Geschichten aufgedröselt. Das hat er ganz prima gemacht und äh ich meine äh
Der Nachfolger jetzt, ich habe mal eine gesehen oder der tritt natürlich auch in eine ziemlich große Fußstapf.
Oh ja, hm.
Er hat es schwer, weil der Peter hatte natürlich auch seine besondere Art es zu erzählen oder zu erklären, die eben auch sehr.
Ein Prixer war, ja, ja.
War, ne, also.
Eigenwillig auf jeden Fall lustig.
Aber äh wir haben uns nie als
Konkurrenz gefühlt, ne? Also was ich mit dem Peter zusammen habe ich noch mal zusammengesessen in Berlin, da kriegt nur beide irgendwie so einen Preis um die Ohren geschlagen, aber da ging's ihm schon ziemlich schlecht, das war kurz bevor er aufhören musste, weil,
zum Schluss war der so krank, da haben sie den dann, ich sah mal aufm Stuhl schon festbinden müssen. Ist jetzt ein bisschen übertrieben, aber äh da war er leider schon sehr krank, aber bis dahin hatte das also wirklich ja,
gut und wirklich toll gemacht.
Ja, er hat auch so eine interessante Distanz auch zum Medium selbst genommen so. Also dieses.
Der der zu und jetzt müsst ihr ausschalten.
Genau das äh ne und äh natürlich hat er auch überhaupt, weil jetzt weiß auch grad vor ein paar Tagen äh ging so im Netz nochmal äh so ein ganz alter Beitrag äh rum von irgendwann in den achtziger Jahren über das Elektroauto mit den er gefahren ist. Ja also
Soweit vor der Zeit, in gewisser Hinsicht auch und natürlich auch so dieses Plakativ in die Kamera getragene alternative Leben war ja dann auch äh in gewisser Hinsicht auch ein Symbol dann auch für so den neuen Aufbruch in der Gesellschaft der achtziger Jahre.
Wir auch gemacht. Wir haben also auch
schon vor langer Zeit alternative Antriebe gemacht, ne, also haben wir so alles, womit man ein Auto fahren kann, vom Dampfauto über ein Auto, das mit äh Kuhscheiße fuhr äh über ein Elektroauto, über ein Wasserstoffauto.
Über ein Auto von diesen äh äh Elsbett sagte, Elsbett Motor irgendwas.
Nee, tatsächlich nicht.
Elsbeth war ein Ingenieur, der früher mal bei den Junckers Werken gearbeitet hatte. Und der hatte zwei Söhne,
die waren auch Ingenieurin. Und die hatten in Rot bei Nürnberg,
eine Firma, die also neue Motoren konstruierte und der war auf der Suche nach einem neuen Verbrennungsraum für einen Dieselmotor.
Und hat da irgendwie was völlig Abstruses entdeckt, nämlich einen Motor, der,
heißer brannte aber nicht gekühlt werden musste, geht gar nicht, aber hat funktioniert und äh.
Als wir da ran kamen und äh also die diesen Motor einfach testen wollten, also der hat uns mit offenen Armen und ah Sender mit dem aus, ja wir gucken das auch immer regelmäßig also so so weit war das damals schon
dann hatte der ähm Motormotörchen ich hatte drei Zylinder, das war so groß wie ein etwas größerer Schuhkarton,
Den hatte der damals in den Mercedes, ich weiß nicht, hundertachtzig oder sowas, ein oder 2hundertzwanzig eingebaut und dieser kleine Motor war so leicht, dass der vorne in den Motorraum bleibt
legen musste, weil der Mercedes eigentlich für die schwere Maschine vorne ausgelegt war, sonst hätte der so gestanden. Und dieses.
So nach vorne.
Eher vorne hochgegangen.
Äh mit diesem Ding bin ich dann von Nürnberg nach München gebrettert mit 180 Sachen und diese Maschine hatte schon über 200.000 Kilometer drauf und die fuhr also sowohl.
Mit Frittenöl. Die sind wir in den Supermarkt gegangen, haben Livio-Öl reingeschüttet. Der fuhr mit allem, was mit Kohlenstoff war.
Äh der ist dann nach der Wende, ich wollte immer wissen, was aus dem geworden ist und habe dann später so jetzt nach 89 mal geguckt
weil das ist eigentlich aus dem Elsberg-Motor geworden, weil ich das unheimlich spannend fand, was der damals äh gemacht hatte. Dann ist der wohl nach Dessau gegangen wieder zurück und hat da versucht, das äh großtechnisch irgendwie auf. Zum ist aber Pleite gegangen und äh leider gibt's die Firma, glaube ich, überhaupt nicht mehr. Äh
was aus den Patenten geworden ist, keine Ahnung. Jedenfalls war's schade, also dieser dieser Motor, dieser der
braucht doch ganz wenig Sprit. Also ich sage mal, vielleicht vier, fünf Liter. Das war unglaublich wie der fuhr. Und äh das war wie ein Rennwagen, aber ich bin auch damals schon
BMW mit einem Elektroauto gefahren, das also auch 160 fuhr und schon eine Reichweite von damals ist. Ist also sicher zwanzig Jahre nicht länger her, von was sich 150 Kilometern hatte.
Bei Mercedes Benz gab's schon einen Wasserstoffauto, so ein Sprinter oder so ein, so ein so ein Kastenwagen. Bin ich mitgefahren,
Ne, also auch mit Elektroautos, also äh und mit dem Dampfauto, das noch zugelassen war, mit Frankfurter Nummer, der richtig hinten noch eine kleine Dampfmaschine drauf hatte und er fuhr also richtig mit Dampfkraft den Berg hoch, ne?
Ja, es war so so eine Pionierzeit auch die,
äh 80er Jahre mit mit Alternative Methoden meinte ich äh gar nicht so den Antrieb, sondern was Peter Lustig betrifft natürlich vor allem auch so sein vorgelebtes alternatives Leben, so dieses. Man kann auch,
außerhalb der ausgetretenen Pfade, wie man so zu leben hat auch äh Leben. Und ich finde, das sind immer schöne Angebote, dass ähm,
Sendung und speziell natürlich auch das äh Kinderfernsehen. Den Kindern halt auch immer so Perspektiven eröffnet, ne.
Einerseits Perspektiven wie's die Maus vor allem macht, denke ich eben über das Wissen ja, aber eben auch so ein bisschen über dieses,
unangepasst sein, dieses man kann auch,
Kann auch anders auftreten. Man muss nicht unbedingt jetzt jeden Quatsch äh mitmachen, nur weil den alle anderen machen. Das äh fand ich eigentlich eine sehr schöne Entwicklung. Und äh auch Wissen macht A äh.
Ein wenig äh
aufgegriffen. Jetzt nicht durch so ein ich sitze äh äh ich sitze im Garten und dann wohne ich halt dort. Aber so durch eine andere Sprache, durch eine andere Frechheit auch durch so eine Unangepasstheit äh im im Verhalten und das äh.
Der Ralf gemacht mit der Schare am Anfang.
Ja, wo geht's ähm jetzt hin mit der Maus? Also es sind ja kein kein Ende.
Wir werden sehen. Also wir haben ja jetzt grade in in diesem Jahr äh zum 50. Geburtstag einfach
viele Blicke in die Zukunft geworfen, also wie werden wir vielleicht in Zukunft leben, wie werden wir in Zukunft uns bewegen und so.
Weil sie die Redaktion hat, sich also zum 50 Geburtstag gewünscht, dass wir eben nicht zurückblicken in die Vergangenheit, sondern eben nach vorne blicken und das geht jetzt sicherlich weiter, ne, also.
Noch eine Figur dazu. Es gab ja die Maus. Später gab's ja noch den Elefanten und die Ente.
Es gab mal äh kurze Zeiten den kleinen grünen Mann, der hat sich aber nicht durchgesetzt
Streichen noch erfunden gehabt. So ein kleines grünes Männchen äh der dann auch immer nur so ein paar äh Laute von sich gegeben hat. Hat sich aber nicht durchgesetzt und.
Ich sehe es nicht, ob.
Wieder nicht real genug, ne.
Ja ja äh ob's da noch eine neue Figur zu geben wird, also,
Müsste schon wieder irgendein wirklich kreativer Kopf kommen, der sagt, okay, da passt jetzt noch irgendwie was ganz anderes dazu. Wobei die Rollen ja,
bei den Dreien ja definiert sind, die Ente schafft immer ein gewisses Chaos. Äh der Elefant ist eigentlich das,
etwas naivere Geschöpf und die Maus ist dann das etwas cleverere Geschäft, wobei das auch manchmal sich umdreht, also dass der Elefanten im Rüssel dann plötzlich ein Nagel in die Wand kloppen kann, wo die Maus dreimal gescheitert, wie auch immer.
Also der Spaß entsteht einfach durch den Charakter der Dreien zueinander, also das ist ähm und
ich wüsste auch nicht, was man dem noch hinzufügen sollte. Also da sind genügend Spielmöglichkeiten gegeben,
Und ich denke.
Hat ja lang genug getragen. Ja also das ist ja jetzt auch schon seit äh ich glaube die Ente ist siebenundachtzig äh dazugekommen. Das läuft ja jetzt auch schon eine Weile.
Jetzt wisst ihr ja sicherlich auch mit einem gewissen Interesse äh auch auf andere Produktionen, schauen auf andere Ansätze, wie so mit Kindern kommuniziert wird, speziell im Fernsehen. Ich erinnere mich noch, was es für eine große Aufregung gab als die äh
mit den Teletubbies an den Start kamen und ja sozusagen auch ganz bewusst versucht haben Fernsehen zu machen für so die aller aller allerkleinsten.
Hast du da eine Meinung und Empfinden zu.
Also ich habe die Teletubbies für einen ziemlich albernes Produkt gehalten.
Aber das ist meine persönliche Meinung. Äh es gibt ja jetzt äh
hier bei uns, beim Sender eben auch eine eine Sendereihe, die für die kleineren ist, die also noch äh jünger sind als die Maus. Äh.
Das gibt's ja jetzt seit einer gewissen Weile und das ist auch ziemlich gut, das äh die machen eben auch ganz andere Sachen, die noch einfacher sind als bei der Sendung mit der Maus und insofern hat,
der Sender hier dadrauf schon reagiert um zu sagen okay wir müssen also noch was machen für die noch kleineren, ne.
Und was sind so andere Formate, die so international noch vertreten sind? Ich meine, Deutschland ist ja in gewisser Hinsicht da auch ja, weiß ich nicht,
äh auch glaube ich äh oft kopiert mittlerweile, ne? Also äh Wissen macht A äh hat ja ohnehin extrem viel äh internationale Erfolge äh
gehabt. Ist also ein viel gruppiertes lizensiertes Format gewesen. Ist denn das Mausformat auch in irgendeiner Form in anderen Ländern aufgegriffen worden?
Das ist eine Frage, die eigentlich nur der Sender beantworten kann. Also ich höre ab und zu, es sei zum Teil in, also einzelne Stücke in 82 Länder verkauft.
Ich habe das niemals nachgeprüft, kann es auch nicht nachprüfen, weil das ist im Sender. Ich bin ja nicht im Sender, sondern ich bin ja äh,
völlig eigenständige eigene Produktionsfirma,
äh ja Australien hat mal ein paar Sendungen übernommen aber ob das fortgesetzt worden ist, weiß ich nicht.
Ich meine jetzt gar nicht so die konkrete Sendung übernehmen, sondern einfach nur dieses Prinzip äh zu übernehmen, die Art und Weise der Vermittlung oder ist das, was deutsches?
Also es ist was deutsches, glaube ich, ja.
So wir wollten ja auch nicht die Sesamstraße nachmachen, obwohl wir also mit unserer Dings, mit unserer Sendung äh früher aufm Sender waren als die Sesamstraße. Allerdings
die Sesamstraße mit dem großen äh journalistischen Aufwand, der dahinter war, dann noch mal ein Schub nach vorne gegeben und äh so ein Bewusstsein für
Programm für Kinder dann nochmal ins breitere Bewusstsein geschafft oder.
Mhm. Mit einem journalistischen Aufwand inwiefern als das ist das darüber berichtet wird. Ja. Okay.
In den Zeitungen und und überall dass da drüber berichtet wurde ja ne also äh die haben ja sehr viel mehr Aufmerksamkeit gekriegt natürlich weil es aus dem berühmten Land Amerika kam und dann musste das ja erst schon mal gut sein.
Von dem Peter von Zahn uns ja schon berichtet hat.
So klar. Und diese,
Gläubigkeit, dass alles Gute aus Amerika kommt oder so was, die war ja bei uns lange lange lange Zeit äh vorhanden,
Alles, was da drüben passierte, war erst mal super.
Und äh alles, was da drüben passierte, passierte mit zehn Jahren Verzögerung dann irgendwann auch bei uns, klar. Und äh,
nur unser Versuch mit der
mit der Maus war früher am Start aufm Sender, ist aber nie so wahrgenommen worden als die Sesamstraße, ne. Höfe hatte ja irgendwie dann hochgelobt und äh ja dann ist ja,
äh der NDR da drauf gesprungen und hat die Sesamstraße nach Deutschland übernommen und die haben ja dann irgendwie weil
die die Voraussetzungen, die die amerikanische Sesamstraße hatte, waren ja nicht eins zu eins auf Deutschland zu übertragen, also.
Die war ja die amerikanische Sesamstraße gemacht worden, um die Kinder aus den sogenannten unterpriviligierten äh Schichten,
zu alphabetisieren oder ihnen zumindestens Zahlen beizubringen oder so was und deren Vertraute war ja Mister Huber in dem Centy Store, weil das in der Wirklichkeit der Bronx oder anderen Städten in Amerika
offensichtlich so war, dass viele Kinder
so ein Mann in dem in der Kamellenbude als einzigen Vertrauten hatten. Und in die die ganzen Figuren wie Grobi aus der Mülltonne und diese ganzen sind auch nur aus den,
oder Oskar äh äh ähm aus äh,
aus der tatsächlichen, wirklichen Umgebung dieser Kinder entstanden oder eben auch der Dings, der ohne Bayern Age von der Bye and Age dann äh äh.
Kaufen, ja?
Ne? So, willst du bitte irgendwas kaufen? Also im Sinne von Haschisch oder sonst irgendwas, wo eben Dinge, die die Kinder da kannten, aus ihrem Umfeld
benutzt wurden, um damit einfach äh was Vernünftiges zu machen. Eben auch die
die Sachgeschichten, die die Sesamstraße ja auch drin hatte, also zum Beispiel wenn in New Yorker Feuerwehr, die waren natürlich
in Deutschland nicht eins zu eins zu übernehmen, weil unsere Feuerwehren hier sahen für die Kinder natürlich ganz anders aus, die Leiterwagen oder so. Insofern hat die äh der Hamburger Sesamstraße ja dann eben auch neue Geschichten machen müssen.
Eigene Figuren auch.
Eigene Figuren auch äh
Ist die völlig anders waren als die amerikanische Philosophie, die auch eher so eine äh vordergründige Pädagogik hatten, äh was die amerikanische Sesamstraße ja nun gar nicht hatte, ne.
Äh insofern hat sich die Sesamstraße in Deutschland natürlich auch deutlich gewandelt äh gemessen an der amerikanischen Sesamstraße, ne?
Ja, hm jetzt.
Fällt mir nix mehr ein.
Ja, ja eigentlich auch schon äh nicht mehr. Ich äh,
Bin froh, dass es so die Maus gibt, muss ich sagen, ist definitiv äh etwas, was sofort erfunden werden müsste. Sollte es das jetzt auf einmal nicht mehr äh geben. Weil es hat äh das Land,
geprägt auf seine Art und Weise. Es ist äh.
Ja, kann man vielleicht annehmen, ja? Ich glaube heute, unter den heutigen äh Zuständen in der Fernsehlandschaft
würde dieses Format nicht mehr erfunden werden können, weil heute würde man sofort sehen, beim ersten Mal, wenn es nicht sofort eine Quote bringt.
Nee, das wird nichts, das lassen wir.
Ja, aber tatsächlich und das habe ich ja schon erwähnt im Internet, ist eigentlich genau dieses Modell von, ich erkläre komplexe Sachverhalte äh in wenigen Minuten und oft eine lustige und unterhaltsame Art und Weise,
durchaus vertreten und eben nicht nur für Kinder und insofern äh war das schon auch ein ein Blick in die Zukunft.
Ja insofern bedanke ich mich auch mal für die ganze Arbeit in all den äh Jahren mal so stellvertretend für alle.
Und ansonsten bedanke ich mich gleich nochmal fürs Gespräch, Armin, vielen vielen Dank.
Und noch einen Dank an euch fürs Zuhören hier bei CRE. Ihr wisst, bald geht's wieder weiter und bis dahin sage.